you know rand paul
must be having a really good day i can
only imagine that when the news broke
about fouchy's emails getting leaked he
started you know jumping up on his desk
and then shuffle dancing and then jump
back down to tweet told you so
and that was just it and i saw the tweet
from rand paul i told you so fire fouchy
and i'm like what told you so what was
told i don't know what the emails
contain rand tell me more
an email january 31st 2020 to anthony
fauci
suggested that researchers believed at
the time
that kovid was engineered
it is only now about a year and a half
later fauci says he's not convinced it
was a coveted was naturally occurring
and lab leak theory is becoming more
prominent it's a very very strange set
of circumstances and while it may be
that the initial assessment was it looks
engineered and then later on they
changed their mind
when you also learn that fauci was
sending emails about gain of function
research and then telling rand paul we
don't do this you are incorrect
and then yeah
and then uh so he was talking about he
didn't understand the context and then
he gets an email apparently from the guy
from ecohealth saying thank you for
shutting down this conspiracy theory
just sounds a whole lot like he's
hooking up his buddy who is being
implicated in the research that may have
led to this lab leak and
costs a lot of lives so we're going to
jump into this we got a bunch of other
news too a disaster has been declared on
the southern border of texas governor
abbott says that joe biden's open
borders policies are just causing drugs
and gangs
and where's where where's joe biden
what's he doing
making things worse i guess well we are
being joined today by the jackpot
ladies and gentlemen i'm here to tell
you that i've heard about this this chat
going on that uh asking about my stance
on cargo shorts
and i'm here to tell you folks that
cargo shorts in the the poso republic
will get you sent straight yeah oh yeah
yeah oh when i'm when i'm supreme
chancellor cilantro fennel uh gone
uh wait cilantro oh yeah absolutely well
it's cilantro later or not jail this is
the problem with cancel culture okay
i will i will lead the cilantro uprising
the cilantro brigade fennel caraway
anise oh god speaking of my love
language
celery is a celery is a jail sentence
not not cilantro is a garnish though
it's not it's not a meal it's a garnish
yeah but they put it in every if it's
like nah don't put it on my stuff i
don't like it it doesn't taste good you
can ask for no cilantro like i'm not a
sour cream guy but yeah but some places
sour cream like i'll go to a mexican
restaurant they're like oh it's all
pre-made oh
you know what i like what do you think
pre-made places for though first i know
that's on you that's on you you go to a
place where they make it in front of you
yeah and i'm always like this i'm always
like extra onions yes extra lemon juice
oh yeah and no cilantro
i want my cilantro i'll pay extra i
don't care you can stuff it in a tube
and then filter water through the tube
and even like fecal contaminated water
and it'll drip out clean fresh water and
then
just grow it in your backyard what
places you're going to eat
[Laughter]
um
hold on hold on i'll compromise we'll
ban cargo shorts okay if you agree with
no cilantro
i can live what is this partisan
bipartisan
sorry about that sweetheart tommy's
gonna be mad at me for that one
50 years like somehow by some twist the
timeline actually is you're in charge of
the republicans i'm the democrats and
we're like we agree and shake hands
we're like yeah i was like
there's like tip o'neill and reagan back
in the day like yes now let's go drink
our fecal juice
everyone's confused as to what this has
to do with anything right exactly it's
like no because we'll have solved
everything else these will be the only
remaining issues that are outstanding
artistic choices yeah i love it all
right we got uh i think ian is chilling
yeah i am thank you tim yes hello ian
crossland up in this house good to be
here that's correct yeah good to see you
i'm very excited jack is here for our
300th episode i'm not sure if this is
momentous my third appearance on the
300th episode wow
wow that's fortuitous i love absolutely
fortuitous yeah you look like leonidas
that's what i was thinking i feel like
leonidas yeah well the whole dying part
yeah and you like kicking p kicking the
messenger into the pit yeah no no i'll
do that all day long yeah especially if
he's wearing he's wearing cargo shorts
yeah all right are we uh are we good
lydia's here she's pushing buttons yes i
am that's me all right everybody before
we get started and talk about the the
craziness which you never know if it's
going to get you banned because whatever
uh go to timcast.com and become a member
click that amazing members only button
and then you will get access as a member
to the members only area where we talk
about a bunch of stuff youtube does not
allow
we talked about the great reset
yesterday before that we had matt
brainer talking about uh voter fraud
issues saying buckle up you'll want to
check those things out and uh after this
show we're going to have another i love
it mega conspiracy bonus episode uh it's
gonna be for members only
if there's a bunch of like really out
there crazy conspiracies about what's
going on right now people have crafted
whole alternate universes they live in
and they're they're fun to talk about
but youtube would probably ban us if we
even joked about these things which is
stupid so it'll just be a fun after show
so make sure you sign up but don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel if you really like the work
we're doing if you think it's important
if you think
we should have more viewers than cnn
share this show take the url put it on
facebook twitter instagram whatever
minds to all the places gab and tell
people hey go watch this show it's a
good show and and otherwise cnn gets
propped up by youtube and they get all
the views and they make all the money so
we gotta fight back so you can go ahead
and do that but let's jump into the news
check this out is there news today was
this official was there anything that
came out today yes well it's new
something a little bit easier
the north east west and south north and
south there'll be news every day that's
right fauci was warned that covet 19 may
have been engineered emails show
the new york post reports dr fauci was
warned the chronovirus has possibly been
engineered and appeared to be taking
reports about it seriously at the same
time he was publicly downplaying the
notion of the virus being created in a
lab according to his emails meanwhile
fauci america's top expert in infectious
disease also got a personal thank you
for backing the natural origin theory
from the head of a non-profit they used
a 3.4 million dollar government grant to
fund research at the chinese lab
suspected of creating the virus on
january 31st 2020 more than two months
before the world health organization
characterized code as a pandemic
fauchi sent an email to us virus
researcher christian anderson and sir
jeremy farrar who runs a global health
charity in britain fauci forwarded them
a copy of a science magazine article our
article titled mining coronavirus
genomes for clues to the outbreak's
origin
this just came out today you may have
seen it if not it is of interest to the
current discussion
wrote fauci the longtime head of the
national institute of allergy and
infectious disease anderson who runs a
viral genomics lab at scripps research
in la jolla california wrote back
the problem is that our phylogenetic
analyses aren't able to answer whether
the sequences are unusual at individual
residues except if they're except if
they are completely off the unusual
features of the virus make up a really
small portion of the genome less than
one percent so one has to look really
closely at the sequence to see that some
of the features potentially look
engineered
anderson also noted that he and others
quote all find the genome inconsistent
with expectations from evolutionary
theory but added quote there are still
further analyses to be done so those
opinions could still change just two
days later on february 2nd ferrar sent a
brief email to fauci and other u.s
health officials in which he asked for a
conference call later tonight or
tomorrow to discuss their response to a
pending announcement from the world
health organization for rather than edit
meanwhile and a link to an article at
the zero hedge website with the headline
quote coronavirus contains hiv
insertions stoking fears over
artificially created bioweapon fauchi
responded that email by forwarding the
email chain to dr francis collins
director of the national
institutes of health and asking do you
have a minute for a quick call
the 3 200 plus pages of fouchy's emails
posted on tuesday by buzzfeed which they
got through a foia request also show
that he and collins corresponded in
april 2020 about fox news reporting on
increasing confidence that the virus
cover 19 started in a wuhan lab
in an april 16 2020 email to fauci and
other u.s health officials colin sent a
link to mediaite report to a media media
report about a discussion on fox news
hannity program colin's email bore the
subject line conspiracy gains momentum
but its entire contents were blacked out
other than the link and his name at the
end
thought she responded to collins email
but whatever he wrote was also blacked
out meanwhile two days after colin sent
his email fauci received a message from
peter how do you pronounce dashik tashak
dashak a zoologist and president of the
eco health alliance quote i just wanted
to say a personal thank you on behalf of
our staff and collaborators for publicly
standing up and stating that the
scientific evidence supports a natural
origin for covet 19 from a batch to
human spillover not a lab release from
the wuhan institute of virology
from my perspective your comments are
brave and coming from your trusted voice
will help dispel the myths being spun
around the virus's origins the next day
fauci wrote back many thanks for your
kind note
last year the wall street journal
reported that ecohealth alliance used
its nih grant to study coronaviruses in
chinese bats and sent the wuhan lab just
about 600 thousand dollars
the five-year grant was renewed for a
total of 3.7 million in 2019 but it was
cancelled in april 2020 under president
trump on the grounds the research didn't
align with the nih's program goals and
agency agency priorities
during april 2020 fauci repeatedly made
public statements suggesting the
chronovirus was the result of an unusual
human animal interface in a chinese wet
market that the mutations that it took
to get to the point where it is now
totally consistent with a jump to of a
species
to animal to human okay okay i i gotta
stop
i think i think the evidence is clear
fauci knew there were there were
suggestions from researchers that he had
contacted that this was engineered
the guy he knows
the guy he was providing funding says
thanks for dispelling the myths where
did fauci come up with the wet market
with the unusual bat to human
transmission of this virus they were
literally doing that coronavirus
research thanks to the money that was
sent to ecohealth alliance
i mean to me it sounds clear-cut fauci
did he make up the story about the wet
market well so the story with the web
market didn't start with fouchy it
starts with the ccp this was
the chinese government's main line that
they were pushing forward they were the
ones who were putting it out there they
were the ones that were talking about
this wet market uh they were spreading
these videos if you remember the bat
soup they actually had this influence or
apologize for doing a bat soup um you
know sort of like
you know tick tock video and starting
this trend and so this was all coming
from this sphere of the chinese
government right which we probably
should have questioned and obviously we
did question very early on to say why
are we trusting the ccp when we know
that the ccp denied that this thing was
going on they denied human human
transmission until
literally the point they couldn't deny
it anymore they were locking up doctors
they were doing everything they could to
hide this information from coming out
but then we just accept their narrative
for how it got out hold on a second so
so fauci contacts virologists in britain
who say it looks engineered
then he sees on the tv from ccp media
it's a wet market he goes it's clearly
the wet market and then he goes on tv
and says well you know that's the wet
market there you go well there's all we
believe that do we trust that so there's
also an email in there um in these early
days this is we're talking remember
january february of 2020. so this is
sort of that early time
where we're all asking questions and we
all of course can see the proximity of
the wuhan institute of virology and
we're you know asking very very rational
questions rational concerns of hey this
is really close to a huge bio lab what's
what's going on with crosstalk
you know what's going on with the bio
lab across the street from the wet
market can we can we see this thing um
and especially for even if even if
someone i i lived in china for two years
but even if someone doesn't know the
geography of china that well
wuhan is about a thousand miles away
from quin ming where these bats actually
reside and where these these main caves
are that they study the coronaviruses
because it's this one huge system of
caves in yunnan province there or yenan
province where um
where they found a lot of this where
where you know the miners have gotten
sick and and all the rest of it so who's
doing the most traveling between those
caves and wuhan well of course it would
be the researchers at the west oh come
on it was clearly the poor wet market
you know salesmen who traveled by foot
with buckets of bats for a thousand
miles and back to sell at the 100 market
right right or the diseased bat just
flew from
the caves all the way to wuhan didn't
get anyone sick in between the 1 000
miles that it traveled didn't stop off
you know you know like when geese fly
south and they stop in my lake no no no
it's not like that no they flew directly
to that wet market why because it was
deliberate
the bats were just like yeah
i i think you know at the time we didn't
have the information we had now look
look these are reasonable questions and
it's it's kind of silly and that's why
we're making jokes about it because you
look at the early days of it and
fouchy's concerns and you look at some
of the concerns about these emails that
are coming in specifically when you talk
about the who they're talking about
tedros who is the head of the who and
they want to get their talking points
straight they want to get this public
narrative this public opinion push
straight forward there's no questions
about you know it you'd expect that from
the bureaucracy standpoint that if
you're you know if this is the movie
version of it right that the scientists
go you know get me on the phone with
wuhan what were you guys doing up there
what came what was happening in that lab
or you know even on the flip side of
that
again the if you take their stated
purposes for conducting these
experiments as hey we're doing research
into coronaviruses a lot of them come
out of china so we it makes sense to do
the research there because we want to
get ahead of there being a pandemic what
wouldn't then follow that you're calling
peter dashak and you're calling your
chinese colleagues to say hey is this
similar to anything you've seen do you
have anything that could maybe give us a
jump on creating some kind of treatment
for this thing that you guys may have
you know come across in the course of
your decade plus long research there
which was the purpose of the research
that was the stated purpose that was
stated purpose of the funding that was
the stated purpose of all these
approvals through ecohealth alliance you
don't see any of that going on
whatsoever what do you see these emails
about talking points the emails about
narrative and then the emails from peter
daschak thank you so much for dispelling
these
to be fair you know uh we we we did a
really good job um we know that fauci
was providing funding to eco health
alliance who were using that funding for
gain of function reach to the wuhan lab
so
who would be better to choose to go and
do the investigation other than the guy
who runs ego all the lines clearly he's
the expert we haven't investigated
and they found nothing wrong and found
that we did nothing wrong thank you
exactly exactly see he's the most
qualified because he's literally doing
look he's literally doing the research
with wuhan lab who why would you pick
someone else he can recognize it can't
he he's the one who knows he can walk in
and say see we're not funding and build
and and doing data function research
here you see
nothing to see you know this is the
president of ecohealth alliance is that
this guy so he the guy who is getting
paid by
whoever voucher or the us government to
do research on back coronaviruses sent
an email to fauci thank him for
dispelling the myth that it came from a
research laboratory yeah yeah but then
like you just came before the street but
then you have to fast-forward too so
it's it's nine months later when the
w.h.o and that's what teams is referring
to when the who sends their team into
the wuhan lot remember there's this big
thing oh the who team is going whoa team
is going who was the leader of that team
wow peter dashak the head of ecohealth
alliance and right as the same guy and
he as i mentioned he has the most
experience so obviously when the lancet
went to do their investigation well of
course we've got to send peter dasha as
well he has the most to lose so you
should let him
let him take control
if i was going to investigate whether or
not you were you know stealing cookies
from the cookie jar and bringing them
into your bedroom i think you should let
me do that
you know your schedule you know your
pattern of life you know your movements
can't lie to myself dude they let her
they actually let the fox in the hen
house that's literally what they did and
then what's funny is so did trump
fouchy's the guy who approved the
funding and let's this let's it's it's
it's not only that and this is you know
i know i'm like supposed to be like mr
you know pro-trump guy but it actually
is under obama that gain of function is
shut down right they put a ban on gain
of function through nih and it's in the
early days of the trump administration
that now keep in mind that guys at the
nih now this is a fife dome right so
collins and so for people to understand
is that collins is essentially fauci's
boss right you know fauci is actually
not the head of the entire nih that's
collins so collins and fauci in the
early days of trump you know kind of
during that transition period they get
this gain of function pause lifted they
get the band lifted and this is where
and you can see in some of these emails
they're talking about the p3 framework
what's the p3 framework this is supposed
to be that if there's anything that
comes up for approval in terms of these
experiments that seems like it's
crossing into that territory that could
be gained a function that it'll go
through this review process and they
bring in outside experts they bring in
this sort of like cadre
to look at it and make sure the
safeguards are followed etc etc okay
that was never done and there's actually
an email from fauci where he's attaching
one of the studies it wasn't your
article there but it's another email
that's out where the study is talking
about gain of function and fauci sending
it to one of his assistants saying hey
was this one of the things that we that
we funded and then he responds and he
responds and says well i don't think so
because i don't see anything in the p3
database so it doesn't look like we've
proved it because they didn't it was
approved through peter dashak and it was
approved through ecohealth alliance and
so it didn't go through the review
process because it wasn't done directly
by nah and this again you know having
spent time working in the federal
government having spent time working in
that bureaucracy you understand these
guys are bureaucrats keep in mind
anthony fauci is our number one paid
highest paid federal employee right you
don't get to that point if you are not
good at the game if you are not good at
civil service so you know do i think
he's this like machiavellian
string puller
puppet master behind the teens no you
know i do think he wants to be seen as
this sort of like uh eminence greece i
have to you know credit to raheem kassam
for giving me that one but sort of like
you know the the power behind the throne
like he wants to be seen as that guy but
i think at the end of the day he's an
institutionalist and he wants to protect
the institution let's talk about the
politics here now so we got the story
from the courier journal senator rand
paul claims vindication fund raises off
of new anthony fauci emails
rand paul questioned fauci and said what
are you asking about do you support the
gate like do you still support he said
does were you conducting gain of
function research i thought i thought he
said like do you still support
right and then fauci is like that is
senator that is incorrect entirely and
completely and completely incorrect
no gain of function research was done uh
that's not true well and this that's
that whole interchange is amazing
because if you go back and watch it
it's he denies that it ever took place
he so he denies any of this funding in
wuhan
so rand paul pushes him a little bit
more on it and then he starts defending
why they funded experiments in wuhan so
in the same exchange to be fair i think
it's self-evident that he was lying
and i i wonder if when dashik the the
ecohave alliance guy
is you know talking to him on the phone
or whatever the communications they're
having outside of email he's like this
is really bad that we're you know our
research may have caused this we need to
get in control of this
so fauci goes on tv and what dispels the
myth they say right and you look at how
early right you look at how early those
emails are you look at how early that
conversation is it february yeah march
this is like the very start and we're
told dismiss not a thing don't worry
about it washington post is is running
headlines debunk debunk debunk why is
debunked because she said so so so i'll
say you know because i take i take the
the more hyperbolic stance of saying it
proves fouchy lied these emails because
in my opinion i think thatch is playing
semantics yes i think i think he
he's playing semantics to try and get
around the fact that he he lied to rand
paul
under oath many people are saying it was
perjury and when he dismissed gain of
function research even though the people
he sent the in the article to were like
oh yeah it looks engineered so he's
lying
i think on top of this
fauci was probably sweating bullets
you hear news about this this coveted
thing and he's probably going like
who did we fund and then he calls
ecohealth alliance and he's like what
did you guys do you okay you've got to
find that that email from his assistant
then because that's what they say that
do we have some
link some distance link that's the
phraseology they use distant link to
this work abroad so it's like they do
everything they can to not use the word
wuhan or wuhan institute of virology
but it seems like they know that there
is an issue going on here and by the way
this whole thing i i should mention this
right you know talking about emails and
foia this is why hillary had set up that
server right because she knew
that foyo get you foil get you if you're
a little loose loosey-goosey with that
stuff and apparently that's what was
going on here in my opinion
that email shows it
fauci was probably you know pulling his
collar going like oh man if this was one
of our programs and how many people died
millions it was like three something
million three and a half three and a
half million oh yeah and that's because
he funded this research now
you're they're not gonna blame him
directly because he provided funding to
an organization who provided funding to
a wuhan lab
but it's still this is this is the you
know the classic michael crichton um
you know phromology of it where
you know you you
you only focused i'm gonna butcher the
line but you know you only focused on
what you could do and you never thought
about whether or not you should right
yeah yeah yeah
so fauci
uh and he has that op-ed now that that's
coming out i think it's from 2012
where he was asked about that oh yes
right the dangers of gain of function
research and what did he say is that
even if it does escape the lab and cause
some it's worth the risk it's worth the
risk it's worth the risk and so this is
what gets me back to my my initial
statement though my thesis is where are
these emails and it's possible that this
was on a different you know okay those
were you know maybe that was classified
maybe that was done on a higher server
because of communication there's all
sorts of reasons that stuffing might
would be classified right and then it
wouldn't show up in foia um i was never
nih so i don't know whether or not they
operate under a classified system but i
understand that if you know obviously
something is at the secret level or ts
level it's not going to be coming out in
a foia that being said um
he easily could have come out and said
yeah we were looking into this and oh by
the way here are the top 10 things we
found in wuhan that are similar to this
this is just like that study that oh
sure jung lee the batwoman and she came
up with this study from a year ago that
these spike proteins that's exactly what
we looked at and here's you know here's
this plan on the shelf see the idea
behind all of this or at least sort of
the you know the raise on debt was that
there would be
an on-the-shelf plan or game plan for
okay we we've this is the one that's
crossed over to the human population
this is the chronovirus that made it
this was this variant so we've studied
it we have an understanding of how it
works these are the best things to use
against it right that was the entire
point
where is that work where is any of that
after a decade what were they doing what
did they what did they ultimately
develop and it seems to be a whole lot
of nothing
and it comes up in ventilators and
remember the ventilators are the big
thing and then matt do masks work do
they not work he tells someone they
don't work then he comes out saying that
what we should anyway because of you
know the percentages in terms of the
population and so
you're looking at this going well wait
you know just just based on what you're
saying you know the whole point of
funding wuhan the 2012 op-ed was that we
would have some you know early warning
system in place
i pulled up the article so it was a it
was a 2011 article i believe the new
york post reports fauci once argued for
risky viral experiments even if they can
lead to a pandemic and now the article
from washington post it's uh it's
actually
you search for google and it pops up
because so many people are clicking on
it but i want to make one point i've
made a couple times in the past couple
of weeks
initially fauci said don't wear masks
and he does this interview on 60 minutes
came out in march and he was like
masks are for people who are infected to
stop them from infecting others
right now people should not be wearing
masks it might stop a droplet but you
know
we don't you shouldn't be walking around
and then in the email that everyone's
sharing it's from february he says
basically the same thing to someone who
asked for advice here's the problem with
this
thought she comes out in july and says
i said that because we knew our medical
professionals needed the ppe because
they're the ones who have to deal with
sick people
but fauci said masks don't protect you
from sick people
so what why would the medical
professionals need it they're not gonna
get the sick person sick and it's not
gonna prevent them from getting sick but
medical professionals still need them i
guess in general okay fine that's fair
but if people
it's it's like why does the x-ray
technician stand behind the thing
because they're the ones there all day
right right so you have doctors with the
masks because they're treating the sick
people
did fauci not consider that if people
wore masks they wouldn't spread the
virus and then the doctors wouldn't need
as many masks because it wouldn't be
working long hours with sick people you
see you see the problem here is either
fauci is a
real [ __ ]
because he doesn't understand cause and
effect
we'll tell everybody not to wear masks
because we and he says on 60 minutes the
mask will stop an infected person from
affecting others then he tells everyone
don't wear the masks because the doctors
need them to treat you when you get sick
because no one was wearing masks
meanwhile the the spread is continuing
throughout the population which means
that a higher percentage of doctors of
course is going to need them so it it is
this sort of interesting thing
where you get into and you know thomas
rates about this where there are certain
people who it seems that when they when
they think about problems they take out
that human element yes right that
element of human nature that element of
like this you could get into a whole
like liberal conservative kind of thing
about this where you know look i i would
love to live in this world where it's
it's just it's utopia and everybody
shares things but human nature is real
and you can't get away from that and you
know this this genius
is why fauci commands what like 430 000
a year from the federal government it it
more than that more than the president
more than the president yeah that's
certainly more than the last time
yeah well trump was giving away a salary
but uh this the president gets four
hundred thousand i actually made more
than last president there you go like
everyone with the last president
because he was getting yeah was it
giving himself a dollar i think i think
he legally had to yeah like do one he
would donate whatever and then he would
still donate that dollar yeah yeah
so uh
for all of this for all of this genius
i thought she gets all that money so i
saw you tweet you said you said that
they're uh actively planning an exit for
the guy yeah so i got a message um late
last night and of course i was up
watching uh batman cartoons
uh which batman actually batman versus
robin so i'm getting into like the old
like the standalone movie series that
came out um i guess from like the 2015
era and now that i've built the suspense
up let's go back to f i know right yeah
so batman was actually really good i
like totally got sucked in i hadn't
watched it and then it was on my plaque
so i was like oh check this out and it's
like real and my kid didn't like it
because it's like it's like much more
adult everyone's on the edge of their
seats right now going just i don't know
it's going super viral so
but but basically they said look
because the emails came out from
buzzfeed right
they can't put it in that sort of bucket
of oh that's conservative media right
it came out from buzzfeed then
washington post apparently had a similar
foia so they came out as well and so it
had to be something that they responded
to and one of the first things no
obviously they're talking about multiple
angles on this but they're saying you
know what
maybe since this thing is winding down
we can look at a potential exit strategy
he's got a book for the good doctor does
he have a book though does he because
so we saw that fauci essentially this
announcement came out about a fouchy
book but then i went on amazon late earl
uh later this afternoon and the listing
was gone totally going well people were
saying you know is he is he profiting
from the pandemic this seems unseemly
they were making comparisons to andrew
cuomo so not you know so it's like you
know it's like woke down play the virus
uh you know a broke down play the virus
woke fun fun wuhan bespoke put the
actual uh you know infected patients in
the nursing home yeah so that's that's
cuomo he's easily next level so
you know i don't know if it's that i
don't know it could it could also be a
legal thing right he's still a federal
employee but it does definitely seem
like there's something going on and that
his his tenure may be maybe coming to an
early did you see how buzzfeed framed
the emails
how how fouchy was trying to keep things
together at a time of chaos my favorite
is my favorite is cnn yes it's
enthusiastic just it's it's a complete
ideography it's it's we're not going to
discuss anything that's actually in the
emails but
you know the fact that he was able to
respond to so many emails while he was
so busy there he is dr fauci exhausted
late into the night responding to email
after email honesty
and then i'm like why didn't they frame
it like the new york post did like early
emails suggest fauci knew the potential
for
uh
lab leak
covet engine it was being engineered
because it feels like cnn is sort of the
last legacy media outlet that is really
on this sort of fouchy train that you
know not only you know not only because
it's like
this is a government employee right he's
a bureaucrat he's he's a he's a leader
we should be skeptical of all right
government employees and government
officials but you know we don't need to
hold them up as some sort of you know
paragon of of wisdom and you know the
oracle adelphi or something like this
you know it's it's he's a government guy
so but cnn is still on that train
they're still trying to sell the fouchy
merch even still trying to do all this
and even buzzfeed's turn i'm thinking to
myself why would they publish any emails
at all because they many of them make
them look bad and then try and frame the
story as a positive not to mention the
implications of mark zuckerberg so
zuckerberg's emails are interesting and
i you know and this is kind of from a
lot of the peter daschak's stuff was
actually kind of out there already so me
looking at it was like well you know we
kind of knew this but it is nice to have
that confirmation because again it
becomes one of those things and you know
it's sort of the journalistic game of
you know it's not what you know but it's
what you can prove in court so the fact
that you have the emails now where they
are discussing gain of function huge
huge monumental right just in terms of
newsworthiness but in terms of the
overall story it just kind of fills in
those gaps so that we basically all
suspected to begin with but the
zuckerberg stuff is super interesting to
me because when you when you look at
the whole situation of
not just zuckerberg and fauci right but
you look at zuckerberg from his perch
throughout 2020 right and so there he is
talking to fauci
in the beginning of 2020 hey how can we
help how can we i i do think he he
probably meant that in you know coming
from a good place i do want like he does
want to help you know so he goes to
fauci and val she's telling him oh we
need the social distancing and then
eventually it becomes lockdowns and
facebook is pushing those
and then later on when the lockdowns are
coming say oh we're locked down how are
we going to have an election and who is
it that comes in and so many people have
reported on this that it's it's these
foundations that are then set up and
funded by zuckerberg chan to help with
the election in many of these cities and
many of these typically trending blue
areas also zuckerberg and it's kind of
one of those things where you really
look back and we say do we as a society
want any one person right
william randolph hearst is a great
example and one unelected person to have
that level of influence in our country
no
especially with hearst it's pretty
obvious what he did with to marijuana
and his tree paper mill industry i don't
know if you're much familiar with hearst
but he had a paper magnet on all these
newspapers decided he didn't like the
competition of people growing in hemp
and making like parchment out of hemp so
he started printing all this propaganda
about why hemp was so dangerous and
driving people insane and used his
propaganda paper to and zuckerberg is
doing the modern version of this where
you go on facebook and you say these
opinions aren't allowed these opinions
are and then you hire and end up
bringing it full circle what were those
opinions
a year ago
oh you could you could you couldn't talk
about lab leaks you couldn't talk about
lab yeah i mean there's still a lot of
stuff you can't say i don't even know if
i'm sitting here waiting like youtube
will eventually ban us i guess steven
crowder was talking about cdc uh uh
numbers and youtube gave him a strike
he got it i hadn't heard that really
yeah steven crowder's been off youtube
for two weeks because they were talking
about cdc guidelines no no i think that
was the first one okay they're they
they've got they had a warning before he
got a strike then he got uh he got a
warning then he got a strike over the
cdc and then the second strike i think
was because they were saying that the
police were justified in the shooting of
mikaya bryant and youtube was like you
were celebrating it so then they had
taken off but the first strike when he
mentioned that he was talking about cdc
guidelines and he said some specifics i
don't want to put words in his mouth but
he was basically just saying like here's
what the cdc says here's what we think
youtube game is strikeforce and so to
your point this this is the problem
right this is the problem with allowing
the social media platforms to be
arbiters of truth because they become
arbiters of discussion and at the same
time going back to the foias now that we
see the falci leaks now that we see the
emails in there he's having the exact
same discussions internally that people
were trying to have on social media zero
hedge of course was sort of the canary
in the coal mine of this because they're
the one of one of the very first places
that was publicly talking about the
wuhan lab they were zapped permabanned
on twitter for this now they were
reinstated but when that first came out
that sent eight people don't talk about
the reproduction oh that was just zero
hedge no no what were the repercussions
of that what was the secondary and
tertiary effects everyone was basically
told the message was sent this topic is
verboten you are not speaking about this
this is like talking this week is the 10
square anniversary um of the massacre
june 4th so it's like talking about
tiananmen square in china right it if
this is done you will be disappeared
that's the message it sent to everybody
that's the freakiest thing about cancer
culture is not only is it top-down
authoritarian you're banned but it's
that people become afraid of even
mentioning it so it's like the
grassroots effect of cancer you know
just like canceling yourself before you
even begin well if you talk to people
who who are from the soviet union my
wife is from the soviet union and she
was born there um
you you realize that because you don't
know where the rules are you don't know
where the fault lines are you don't know
where like the ideological landmines are
you know am i supposed to like this
person or hate this person that kind of
stuff
the only way to really be safe is to not
have opinions right is to not question
anything not have opinions on things
it's to shut down in a very internalized
way so the the overall
you know the final end state of cancel
culture is that you're canceling your
own mind you're canceling your own
opinions you're cancering your
individuality um and that's and it's
internal the sensor is actually in you
don't need you know the ministry of
truth because that's just in your head
every day
that really disturbed me that really
disturbs me because then they're
removing themselves it doesn't have to
be the government it doesn't have to be
facebook it doesn't have to be i'm not
saying by the way i'm not saying tanya
is like that you know right
she's been america or she uh she she she
makes she makes her opinions known
remember that photo from uh uh it was a
soviet union and there's like stalin
he's on a boat
next to him yeah but then like all of a
sudden there's another photo and there's
like no guy next to him what was that
called they have a name for that or a
word for what they were doing with
history so airbrushing you know back in
the day yeah airbrushing but you know
what they call it airbrushing one thing
one thing it reminds me of something i
heard from a north korean defector once
who was talking about this situation and
he said
you know and it's it's not as uh it's
not as nice as the way stolchenin would
put it but you know the defector said
look
we know that they're lying about the
united states we know that they're lying
about the western world like we know
that you're not just killing each other
all the time and it's like you'd race
war and racial strife constantly we know
it's not like that right and and this
chaotic situation but the problem is
because of the censorship we don't know
what the truth is yeah so we don't know
what it actually is like so because we
have no we have nothing to verify it on
we have nothing to compare it to let's
talk about how scary things can really
get i got the story from the hill
washington post issues correction on
2020 report on tom cotton lab leak
theory
now that headline from the hill is
irresponsible in my opinion because they
did not issue a correction
they issued what's called a stealth edit
which i'm sure many may be familiar with
but let me show you this tweet from greg
price greg is uh he's just he doesn't
have a bio but he's verified on twitter
that pro that means everything greg's a
daily caller daily caller there you go
yeah he's great he's good he tweets
democracy dies in stealth edits on 15
month old headlines
the first image the washington post says
tom cotton keeps repeating it
coronavirus conspiracy theory that was
already debunked
and now it reads
tom cotton keeps repeating a coronavirus
fringe theory that scientists have
disputed
so what happens is
right now it's happening across the
board on he's been upgraded from
debunked to fringe that's right that's
conspiracy to fringe
and disbelief
right
it's not the only outlet doing this
congratulations senator
these news outlets are literally
rewriting history there think about what
it used to be like in the past 100 years
ago oh this is winston smith what what
what is this night this is the plot of
1984 there you go that's his job right
right in the beginning is he's the guy
who edits old newspapers so but but in
reality 100 years ago a newspaper would
come out and it would say you know
jackpot does backflip and you'd be like
there it is it's reported and there's a
photograph of jack doing this amazing
backflip you should see my back club
it's the best nowadays there will be an
article on you know washington post
website and it'll show the backflip and
then a month later without anyone
noticing the article will be different
and it'll say jack pasobic falls doing
backflip
and the photo is still there but it
looks a little different it's a
different photo or it's gone all
together see back in the day a hard copy
wouldn't be changed right they would
have to issue a correction later on if
they made a mistake in the next paper
today they don't even issue corrections
they just change the articles now here's
where it gets crazy wikipedia supposed
to be this great encyclopedia of the
modern era right
how many articles on wikipedia use that
washington post story that says debunked
conspiracy
the story's different now do we go and
delete all those encyclopedia entries
that are now incorrect this is a huge
problem with how we are collecting and
disseminating information in today's in
today's era
news organizations can just change what
they said a year and a half later and
then our encyclopedias don't make sense
anymore because what so if someone were
now to write an article related to coven
they could use this article the same
link to make a different point they
could say it you know it was a fringe
theory scientists dispute it well as
another article says it's a debunked
conspiracy theory so these
inconsistencies will start popping up
the more they do this and to to to
piggyback what you're saying
if
let's say you've been living under a
rock right for the longest time you're
just someone who's like total normie not
interested in any for whatever reason
you're not interested in covet 19 you
you know but you you want to learn about
it now you say what's this lab leak
theory people are talking about i want
to dig into it a little more and they
say oh cotton brought it up and it was
disputed back then but that's not true
right so if the washington post wanted
to tell the truth they could have said
yes it was considered a conspiracy
theory when it was first talked about
however over time it gained traction and
here's why it gained traction and here's
the actual story of it but this is the
problem because they don't set
themselves up as
i mean think about you don't have to
have a position on anything anymore
right because your position is we are
the truth and so if we are truth then
whatever truth is can become
a living target instead of it being what
uh uh what the truth is we will report
what they're saying now is what we
report is the truth is the truth right
exactly so it doesn't matter what really
happened it matters what they decide to
put on paper and that's a problem that's
a huge problem
it has been that way to an extent for a
long time but now stealth editing has
become so widespread and when it comes
to very serious historical moments like
this
this is actually really scary you know
why
if we're not collecting information in
any other capacity i mean i suppose we
have archives we have you know archive
that is we have the wayback machine
what happens in 50 years in 100 years
and they're like what happened with
covet and they look back at all the
articles and it says lab leak was
confirmed very early on tom cotton so so
right now it says tom cotton pushes
fringe theory great in a year i'll say
tom cotton pushes proven theory they're
gonna go back and rewrite history we
knew the whole time tom was right
so what happens in 100 years history
will be dramatically different
we witness it we witness the media lying
but future generations are going to look
back at the archives and they'll be like
they were always right
see washington post wrote tom cotton is
correct about lab league theory that's
the headline says no and they rewrite
the story why change it why not just put
like you know the guardian does this the
thing up here says this article is three
years old right yeah i actually like
that even though i don't like the
guardian right
but i actually like that they put that
up because even if it's it's one of
things where
you know someone will someone will do
this on twitter to get retweets
sometimes um where they'll post like an
old article but they'll make it seem as
if it's breaking
and it's something yeah you know what
i'm talking about and then it starts
getting shared a lot well and i want i
don't know if guardian was thinking
about this and the sort of the social
media interplay where people only read
headlines anymore um because that's
what's happening more and more is that
when you do click it the first time that
it'll show hey just so you know big
blinking letters this thing is several
years old this information could be out
of date and by the way that's okay yeah
because things change in life right you
know stories have a beginning middle and
end sometimes they keep going sometimes
you get the mcu and there is no story
all right oh
oh we got jokes folks we got jokes and
um
or you get the simpsons where it just
kind of like trails off into like the
oblivion but you know it it allows you
to sort of understand this and this is a
plot in actually a lot of movies where
you're going through the microfiche and
you're understanding oh so this this
happened here and then this happened and
then you're able to weave the narrative
together well if you don't have that
then how do you figure out anything what
i really love about this media
phenomenon is that there are a lot of
organizations that will do an
aggregation of say the ap or reuters
right and so it'll just say like yahoo
news and then it'll say new york post i
find this all the time because yahoo
news will pick up a lot of yeah he news
is really weird like that and that
because they have some some that are
that are internal but a lot that are
from somewhere else and it'll just say
new york post so what's funny is the new
york post will put out a story and then
issue a correction and yahoo news will
run the uncorrected the false version
and they both simultaneous
simultaneously exist
as certifiable credible organizations
for wikipedia's editors and newsguard
certified so you can literally just pick
which narrative works best for you i
suppose what happens then choose your
own reality well as we know people
choose news which confirms their bias
yep so the conservatives will find the
corrected piece and go oh right there
and they'll post it on facebook and the
democrat liberals and those in the
leftist will be like oh right there the
yahoo version they'll post it and now
you have two versions of the same story
i'll tell you what though man
it really does feel like uh there was an
article written in am great american
greatness by um man i forgot the guy's
name but uh he he writes that the
democrats have already seceded from the
union talking about the the crazy things
they're doing they don't believe in the
history of this country they don't
believe in the rule of law they've
intervened in in the chauvin trials
demanding violence clearly they're not
working in the same capacity as we are
and i look at that number by the way you
see chauvin he only he i say he said i
only want you know if i want a new trial
number one but number two i should only
get probation because the system is
completely broken yep well so this is
interesting
i remember the sandlin hearing probably
the most
important example of what's happened to
this country
i was uh
i can't remember where the images is
from
but there's i think it was at the gym
and there's two tvs side by side there's
fox news and there's like abc this is
the first impeachment yeah uh
this was ukraine gate yeah so well that
was the first impression yeah so we
don't even talk about it anymore sandlin
actually was the second one
donald trump told me no quid pro quo
right
but i kind of felt like there was one
so fox news the chiron says
sandlin quote trump said no quid pro quo
right on the tv to the left of it
sandlin confirms quid pro quo
how can we function as a country when
people are like fox news is lying it's
fake news i'm like but they quoted the
guy they quoted sondheim what he was
saying
and then they're like but abc news they
they get to the truth and then
conservatives look and they're like
that's a quote if you can take one
sentence and turn it into two completely
opposite news stories and it results in
people at each other's throats
mass conflict in the streets riots
i don't see how we come back from that
well and the problem is and it's
something that you know you've talked
about a ton but i think we've all
experienced it where so many of these
outlets have gotten away from hey and
we're not going to be arbiters of truth
we're going to be arbiters of narrative
because we're chasing an audience yeah
he's chasing clicks have you seen the
project verita veritas deposition of
lauren windsor no i haven't seen that
so i don't know the full context it's
just one of the clips i saw from from
james o'keefe they put out talking about
you know swinging the new york times and
all that right and they asked this woman
and i i may be getting this wrong so
just double check and go watch the video
but they said something sue us all if we
get it wrong no they know it's kind of
but but uh the the lawyers asked uh asks
the lawyer asks this woman
why didn't you include this video in
what you were producing and she just
like shrugs and goes
because it wasn't necessary for the
narrative we were trying to produce
and and i hear that i'm like the
narrative you are trying to produce
that's crazy well you talk to you can
figure this out if you go to any
journalism school right and talk to any
student there you know we should get
like fleccas or somebody or campus
reform to do one of these you know sort
of man on the street interviews with
with um with journalism school
uh students and people studying that
major if they have any you know if you
go back to campus learning and ask and
ask the question then again
of
why are you going journalism school why
do you be journalists the answer i
guarantee you 90 because i want to
change the world because i want to
change the world because i want the
world to be a better place i want this i
want that for the world and i want that
that power of journalism to get me there
okay great but that's not journalism no
that's activism that's that's not it's
like that uh you saw that woman from the
ap who got fired right the
pro-palestinian woman oh yeah so this
woman gets hired by the ap then there's
like she she starts complaining there's
a right-wing smear campaign not just
pro-palestinian by the way i mean she
was like
the pro-hamas in some cases like
anti-israel yeah variance but but for
for me even right i'm i'm not gonna even
play the political argument i'm gonna
i'm gonna tell you why she should have
been fired period
so
whether or not you want to get into her
politics or anything like that there's
one simple fact she gets hired by the
associated press
there's a bunch of people complaining
she's she's pro palestine she's
anti-israel
and the they she argues these were past
tweets and the left says their old
tweets it shouldn't matter
i said why does she want to be a
journalist
when she is an advocate for one side of
a conflict
what was the point of her trying to get
that job the ap was right to fire her
and they should have fight they should
have never hired her
someone comes to me and says hey i'd
like to report on the southern border
crisis i'd be like
i'm down we could do some reporting and
then i see in their twitter it's all
just vitriol about trump and you know
and and the kids in cages i'm going to
be like i don't think you're actually
going to report on this
if i want to hire an activist to do
advocacy i will i want to see a report
from someone who's like dry and says i
spoke with the the president's
administration you know tom homan said x
y and z though the activist
organizations say a b and c okay that's
reporting
instead what's happening is activists
are trying to get jobs at news
organizations they've succeeded greatly
and now that she got fired because she's
an activist and the ap said she tweeted
after the fact i looked at her i looked
at her current tweets yeah they're very
out she's retweeting people who are very
pro-palestine like how can anyone expect
to get legitimate news from someone who
is advocating for an outcome in the
conflict
she's going to tell you bad information
but the activists are claiming it's free
speech under attack and it's a
right-wing smear campaign because they
are subversive and trying to inject
activists into media because they know
if you control the narrative you control
people have access to if they don't know
the truth they can't fathom the truth if
the only thing they hear is your
propaganda they will side with you
they've been doing it for a long time
and it's working it's one of the times
they failed and they only failed i don't
even think they failed because of ben
shapiro they're like it's ben shapiro's
fault you know he was smearing this
journalist like well i mean
the ap said it was unanimous they looked
at her tweets and said nah you
you can't work here you can't do that
and the real question is of course you
know why did that not come up in the
review process in the hiring right so
maybe you can hire that person and not
say hey what did they put on social
media did we're gonna talk about a
specific issue we want you to report on
this
what's your past work on that you know
let's let's see let's let's see you're
real you know if i'm if i'm getting
someone in you know um you know in terms
of videos like hey let me see your reel
let's see your sizzle reel right what do
you got what do you got for me oh okay
so you're you're completely in the tank
for this one side think about how in my
opinion you'd have to be really dumb
to even consider doing this
let's say this person
who is you know anti-israel
pro-palestine says i want to be a
journalist and i'm going to go and i'm
going to report from this place it's
like what do you think's going to happen
if some of these like very strong
results of the other side get wind of
your reporting you've got
ap says we'd like you to go and
interview this zionist extremist
really out there guy
street you know group of people they're
going through the streets and they're
they're angry and crazy and then this
journalist is going to show up and
they're going to be like we looked at
you we looked at your twitter history
you you think that you're going to
engage in act in in in in propagandizing
for one side of a conflict and be able
to go and interview the other side
they're going to be like you're you're
clearly not my friend
first of all you can't get the interview
so even if it was just activism
but let alone the fact that you might
actually be perceived as a belligerent
like actually coming to do them harm now
that's mostly true of anti-fun what
we've seen in new york and stuff it's
typically not the israeli groups the
pro-israel groups that are going around
attacking people so i'll make sure
that's clear
but you can't expect to do an interview
at all if if if a journalist shows up
and tries to interview someone on the
right you know i i you know and
shameless book plug but like i just did
the antifa book it just came out into
the book.com but we get into this where
uh julio rojas from town hall where he
would go
and
he's at these events and just trying to
be there as media and he's like i want
to just interview people who are part of
antifa who are trying to you know i did
this myself in 2017 and you know has
gone out there um you know i hope
everything's okay with andy right now of
course know that you know he's got a
situation but was that him uh
i don't know for sure if that was him
and but he hasn't tweeted since we've
reportedly the situation put it that way
just regardless hope he's safe um you
know i pray for the guy and but you know
that these these antifa groups they will
get if they see you filming regardless
of who you are unless they know right
there's something came up when i was in
chaz and if they don't recognize you and
they know you by sight or they you know
they've kind of seen you around the
scene before they you know have some
kind of an idea of you or or most likely
they've been following you on social
media and so you're sort of an approved
documenter they will get in your face
they will put up umbrellas they will
attack you they will assault you they
will milkshake you they will you know
try to push you down concrete steps like
they did to me at the lincoln statue uh
last year so if you are identified as
someone who is
you know seen as a conservative or even
someone who's just not on our team right
you are pushed out you are not allowed
to do anything with this and this is
actually they handed so with julio in
his situation this is in dc i believe
they actually handed him a list of if
you're going to cover us you have to
follow all of these rules you can't you
can you can't film something where
someone's committing a crime you can't
film anyone's faces if their mask comes
off uh you can't film if anyone has
their phone out any of these different
things that could possibly identify them
right and they are setting these and so
the question then becomes if you are
someone who considers yourself a
journalist and you're going in and
embedding or at least getting close to
these events are you following those
rules and if you're doing so then are
you taking their side of course
you're working for them you're licking
their feet let me i'll tell you a story
i went to boston and there was a right
wing pro right wing thing i think it was
like 2018.
and there was a left-wing counter antifa
group shows up the first thing i have to
point out
what were the right-wing individuals
holding
they were all holding some kind of
object
they were holding shields what were the
antifa people holding
what do you think two by fours clubs
crowbars bats two by fours and so i'm
like clearly someone's come here to
fight and beat people and clearly
someone's here uh seeking to defend
themselves but something interesting
happened
there was a a an individual who looked
like a lefty but was a journalist taking
pictures of both sides but was wearing
like some like you know lgbt pride stuff
right and they went over to uh take
photos of the right wing group
some guy a couple guys on the right
started screaming you know fu antifa and
the three percenters who were there
immediately ran up and stopped the right
wing guys and told him to shut up back
off and let them take photos really yeah
there was there were several periods
where the right were trying to get rowdy
and the three percent has immediately
told him to back off and we're screaming
at him so the three percent of guys that
were there were just wearing like
they didn't have any weapons they were
wearing like some kind of light tactical
gear but didn't really have much with
them and they were telling people on the
right to chill out back up get away so
when someone from the left would come
over they would immediately turn around
and tell the right to chill out well i
think that was the right move because
i'd imagine these guys on the right
would pummel one of these antifa guys
pretty bad they're by themselves walking
over you know what i mean
so what do i see when i when when i walk
over to the antifa side and i i'm
dressed like a right wing guy i get i
get a guy swinging at me he's he hits my
phone a couple times getting my face he
tells me to hit him and
that that's the difference between what
happens when you go and try and report
on these things the people on the right
i can walk i can walk into you know i go
back to occupy wall street era i show up
at cpac it's like 2012 cpac and i'm
walking around and literally nothing
no problems nothing happens people are
like how's it going have a nice day
that's it
you show up to one of these occupy
protests even when i was down there and
half the people liked me i still had
antifa attacking me
i was physically attacked three times in
new york during occupy wall street
proper
physically attacked by these people and
they supposedly liked me
so why would why would a journalist want
to be involved in that
you have to basically just tell them you
have to say whatever they want you to
say
so you're not really doing reporting
well so we go i got into this a little
bit in my chats chapter as well because
when we when we talked about
the journalistic failures that were
going on and actually chief carmen best
who was this the police chief that
resigned in
in seattle in the wake of all this um
and has said that it was like a
disinformation campaign because here's
what would happen is the dynamic was the
media would go there most of the
mainstream media would go during
including fox news would go there during
the day right they would set up they
would have their huge cameras their huge
lights they would do a hit and you know
during that time you get like the day
trippers you get tourists you get people
just there with their kids walking
around and it is sort of generally a
sociable atmosphere you know people
you know drugs are kind of you know
freely going around there's no police
remember that was the whole thing there
was no police for 12 blocks so
then at night all of those reporters
would leave and they would go back to
their hotels or go to the bar and drink
craft beer whatever they'd leave
that's when all of the violence was
going on that's when the black blocks
would really start coming out in force
that's when you actually saw criminal
gang elements that had nothing to do
with the social justice or antifa
aspects of this but would come in
because hey there's no cops here so we
can go commit crimes and we can go do
deals where we don't have to worry about
being caught that's also where you then
got those shootings there were five
shootings on four separate occasions all
throughout chats happened right after i
left and i said this is going to be a
bubbling cauldron of violence i said
that you know as i was walking out i
pulled my mask off and we kind of did
like a live stream saying you know this
is going to get bad jenny durkin who was
the mayor now is not running again by
the way in seattle because i think we
know what happened there um it's
you had people dying you had people
being shot you had people being killed
because
and reportedly this the investigation is
still open but a lot of those early
reports were that it was the chad
security the john brown gun club that
had actually been involved in some of
these shootings because they were had
this paranoid belief that and they were
very specific about this that the kkk
was about to show up and raid chats not
the boogaloo boys not proud boys not i
mean they knew who proud boys were but
they they were all certain that the kkk
of seattle which apparently they think
is a thing i've i've never heard or seen
anything we got we got we got to stop
using we got to stop using their words
it wasn't it wasn't chad security it was
terroristic insurgents precisely so that
what we often see with these conflicts
is that the left will say it's uh george
floyd square
and then what happens is the media shows
up and they film the peaceful
inhabitants at george floyd square
except for you know a couple weeks ago
when 30 gunshots ring out in the report
it was by shooting square well exactly
and so we keep referring to these things
the way they demand they be referred to
well this is why with the whole chaz
chop thing right so they realized very
early on that chaz was really really bad
branding in their part right capitol
hill autonomous zone and then the minute
that media narrative got out and people
said wait what do you mean you've
declared yourselves autonomous you're
autonomous from the united states your
own country within a couple of days they
get up no no we're just kidding we're
actually the chop we're just it's just
an occupied protest we're trying to
bring back some of that get good will
from you know zakati park and the
original occupy no no no but what did
conservatives do a lot of conservatives
adopted chop i never did i wouldn't even
call this all the way through i won't
even call it that would you call it a
no-go zone it was a no-go that's it
that's was that this was of course i
went there a far-left extremist no go
zone you look at the definition of a
no-go zone look at the standard
colloquial understanding it means a
place where the police are reticent to
go
or they the medical professionals uh ems
police they don't want to go there
because it's too dangerous individuals
only enter with great personal risk
that's exactly what these places are so
we actually tracked one of the guys who
was a member of this giant or at least
suited up to join the john brown gun
club in jazz
and
daniel allen baker this is a guy who was
later arrested early 2021 down in
tallahassee florida why because he was
planning a left-wing
armed action at the at the florida court
excuse me florida capital right daniel
allen baker he goes out there travels
from florida to chaz to create to be
this sort of militia security group
where did he have his training
he's one of these antifa guys that
actually went to syria
to join the battlefield forces of the
ypg this is the kurdish group that's out
there they're tied to the pkk who are
terrorist designated group he's actually
out there on the battlefield but of
course because they were fighting isis
at the time and you know sort of more
infighting for the kurdish areas you get
all these stories in rolling stone he's
actually in one of the vice
documentaries from syria talking about
how great it is that these these
left-wing just true believers are out
here fighting for something fighting for
their own land right it was almost sort
of like they're trying to create this
stateless space up there in northeast
syria he comes back has the training
from the battlefield has the ttps he
goes up there in chats and we've got
these these quotes from him we've got
tweets from him
and he's saying look if we really want
to have an autonomous zone we've got to
take this to the next level need we need
more guns we need explosives we need all
sorts of things i'm quoting him by the
way
wow and we need to take this to the next
level because eventually the police are
just going to come in here and shut this
down but god he was really pushing them
to go forward now of course we know that
didn't happen but that very same guy
claims he claims uh that he was one of
the medics involved in one of these
shootings
the question is of course was he there
as a medic or was he there or something
else or
one of the people that stripped all the
evidence out of the vehicle when they
pumped it full of hundreds of rounds
killing two teenagers precisely
so the kill they killed one that time
the other ones arrived the other one
survived yeah and now there's i think a
couple lawsuits
these people who are killed the parents
are blaming the city
i mean the city could have come in and
swept it all up but these these these
democrat leaders they're
they favor this stuff
right and it is it does kind of create
the moral question of you know
do the people of the city now do they
deserve it no obviously not and this is
why i keep telling people just get out
of city so you can just you just need to
be out of cities for a while because a
lot of the people in the cities you look
at places like i'm i'm from the
philadelphia originally uh they just
re-elected the d.a who's like let's
let's not prosecute people let's let
people out of jail uh larry krasner so
that he just won the primary handle
handily won the primary there so they
are voting for this kind of stuff st
louis same situation right st louis
which is now one of the murder capitals
in terms of homicide rate of the united
st louis right who would have thought
right that that would have been you know
ferguson i know you're at ferguson um
and so
if they're voting for this again and
again right the question is is is this
what they want let me ask you a question
so so jack just mentioned there was a
guy
in uh this was the the seattle no-go
zone with the terroristic insurgents of
the far left and he was talking about
how they wanted to escalate things but
it never happened this guy who wanted
violence and explosives was he
prosecuted was he locked up to the feds
come and and arrest him they put out his
photo and say please help us stop this
dangerous terrorist
uh
yes but not for that not until much much
much later when he said that he was
going to do something at the tallahassee
capital in florida in 2021 for all of
his activity again going to the middle
east and training with the terrorist
designated group
going to chas being involved in all this
stuff not prosecuted
so so so here's a guy
far leftist
they didn't care about his his his
goings on in in seattle complete and
there were a lot of other people has
anybody been arrested over the murders
no i got a story for abc news
prosecutors drop case against a man
charged in capital riot federal
prosecutors have dropped the criminal
case against a new york man who was
accused of participating in the right at
the u.s capitol
the
fbi went and arrested a man
because my understanding is a paid
informant this told the fbi he was in
the capital and they said
good enough for us
went arrested him turns out he wasn't
phone evidence apparently proves he
wasn't they never had evidence yet
they're gonna go and track this guy down
on the ward of some random nobody but
these antifa extremists nothing on this
one i did you actually pull up the
charging documents on that no oh so i
actually went into that earlier today
and i was looking at it first as a story
for human events um we're still probably
going to do it but i wanted i want to
give it to it justice but
since you brought it up i'll mention it
this paid informant
sounds like and again it's they're very
vague about it because they're trying
very hard to make sure that you know
they're not revealing their source on
this
he was in a facebook group chat and it
appears that he was in the group chat
prior to january 6
that he was already there so just
taking that information as it is you're
looking at a capability you're looking
at a tactic the fbi is using they are
paying people to go into facebook group
chats and keep track of what's going on
in there yep and and so the question
then becomes
as you're looking through there now
again they're not showing the actual
messages in this chat because i think
that might reveal who it is they're just
referring to the messages so it becomes
very hard to tell whether the guy
they're talking about is the one who
actually went in or whether it's
somebody else who was in the group chat
because even i remember having been you
know in in the capital on not excuse me
not in the capital in dc
on january 6 um but being in that area i
was across the street at the one of our
canoe studios cell service was down
right you could not get access anywhere
so it would be very uh very interesting
for me to to hear that somebody was in
the capital and able to post into a
facebook group chat in real time right
right that almost to me makes it sound
like he wasn't in the capitol because i
was having to make phone calls from the
side of the street to people who were
outside the area with access to be able
to tell me what was actually happening
inside is that the first time this has
happened we had the story of women in
alaska yep she she posted a photo
outside wearing that was an informant
that was that was something else that
was the feds just being like we got her
and then arresting the wrong person no
that was if you looked into that
that wasn't the first incident that she
was involved in if you look in terms of
the timeline of when she came across
their radar she was involved in a mask
dispute with alaska airlines right right
and and that's when an airline employee
it seems like well we don't know for
sure but it seemed like it was the
airline employee then thinks i want to
do something about this woman i'm very
upset at her so then goes on to fbi's
list of the faces that are pointed out
and that have all been listed somewhere
and said yeah you look kind of like that
one and um we're gonna and so i'm gonna
send this to the fbi and say that you
are definitely that person and so the
fbi says hey we've got the word of an
employee they've identified you this is
this is the person we're coming and they
raided her house on all this now by the
way going back to you know i'm not going
to say circle back
they're going to do that not going to
use that phrase
thank you jen we love you so much um but
no uh
when it comes to antifa when it comes to
these no-go zones when it comes to the
anti-fascist anarchist terrorism this is
never done right we we see their faces
so many times we see the live streams
this is never done i gotta argue with
you you call them anarchists they're not
anarchists well they're
anarcho-communists
they're not antarctica communists
they're affordances they're tankies
they're authoritarian communists you get
a swath of both yeah but but uh
true
anarchy
it means without authority right so left
anarchists are like hippies sitting down
stoned and just not fighting if you if
you've actually ever seen like i'm sure
you know and caps yeah of course they
have the non-aggression principle
that's a much more well-defined ideology
uh libertarians and end caps you know
it's the free market don't aggress on me
the actual lefty anarchist because i
knew a bunch at occupy
are were absolutely opposed to fighting
with cops being confrontational these
are the people that would like sit in
circles in the street like sing kumbaya
because they also agreed with you can't
assert force over someone else that's a
form of authority what happens is you
get these authoritarian communists and
you know there's there's there's varying
degrees of authoritarian between them
the tanki's up in the far left of the
quadrant who are like take over kill
everyone who opposes us but then you
have some who are like we'll take it by
force it's the only way
none of those people believe in a system
without authority they believe they are
the authority they believe they have
they are the ones who have the moral
authority to determine what is and and
and isn't and they will use physical
violence against you which is the
epitome of exerting authority against
another person
they do however use the word anarchy to
describe themselves however disguise it
what if they're fighting fascism no no
no no no because it's not because this
is no but i'm saying this is what they
use as sort of the justification in many
of these cases this goes back to the
original antifa in weimar germany that
they're not anarchy the system is
fascism the uh the police are fascism
the military's fascism banks are fascism
the church is fascinating
those were communists anti-fascists
they specifically called themselves
communists well this is where i say
anarcho-communists but the the actual
anarcho-communists like they're lying to
you basically
i agree with that yeah they're
definitely lying so
the reason i i i want to i always try to
clarify on what anarchy is because if
these people truly believe
anarcho-communism
is hippies on a farm that's it
it doesn't scale up there's no
you know
10 000 members you know a citizen city
that's not communistic it's impossible
so what ends up happening is the more a
a left anarchist wants to grow their
society the more authoritarian they
naturally become
they call themselves anarchists
often because they're trying to recruit
people into believing they're the
peaceful ones who want to empower you
but they're lying so i don't like using
their language some animals are more
equal than other animals like if you
talk to uh like michael malus sure he's
a huge fan of of anarchy and anarchism
and i'll tell you what it actually is
yeah i actually um so i just
i got his book as well where i i think
it's actually a
it's like essays on anarchism but it's
it's like a compilation so he wrote some
of it right and then it's other essays
and so we actually cover some similar
topics so we both talk about leon
cholgash who was the anarchist that
killed mckinley um we talk emma goldman
comes up in both now obviously his head
is a much more in-depth understanding
just of anarchism but it's interesting
that we are both covering the same thing
but i think from different perspectives
yeah i i view it like you know i've had
long that's just one chapter for me yeah
yeah i've had i've had long discussions
with a lot of people from like occupy
wall street and the leftists and i'm
like you know how do you define
authority right and they typically will
say you know like the people who control
the system the top of the hierarchy blah
blah blah and then we we inevitably get
inevitably get down to the philosophy of
so it isn't occupying a form of
authority though
uh
it it depends it depends on so so
obviously you have the power principle
that exists in the in the woke left so
that's what you're talking to but they
typically will say
that you know authority is you know the
people who control the system and
determine
you know what is or isn't and i say how
do they control that system they say
with the police state with violence and
with force and i say okay so the
exertion of physical force against
another person to make them right do
what you want that's authority and they
were like yes and i said so when you go
out and smash windows and start fires
and beat people what's the difference
you just don't have the same level of
power they do but you certainly seem to
want it and believe in it so this came
up one night when we were at chat this
this whole like lord of lies hobbsian
reality where
there was a guy who was accused of theft
remember this and so you know not to go
through that because i mean there was a
whole thing it was like a you know he
broke into a car dealership and
he's he was essentially stealing keys he
was accused of stealing keys as well as
a jacket he he gets held by the owner
then they chase him out then the whole
sort of bulk of people hear about this
they tear down the street my brother and
i are standing right there as this is
all going on we were just like
interviewing some guy when it when we
turned the mob is just charging up the
street at us and and you know brother
said what do we do i said
start running i guess you know see
what's going on keep filming right and
and so we do we keep filming they knock
down the fence they get in the guy bolts
he gets away but
in this guy
being who he is he comes back later
trying to like act as if he's part of
the group like hey guys what's going on
and meanwhile the son of the dealer
owner is is right there saying hey
you're wearing my dad's jacket you're
you're clearly the guy who who just
tried to rob jack
yeah you know
um retired nypd guy in a class i was in
once said you know in the intel
community has said like you know most of
the people that that you know resort to
crime aren't necessarily the smartest
people to begin with so you know and he
was like trying to give like sell people
chips out of a bag it's like a backpack
so they start chasing him again once
they identify him they grab him they
hold him up and right so razz right sort
of the rasimone the warlord razz right
is there at this point he he [ __ ] and
locks right in front of me and starts
running down the street after this guy
with the son
of uh the car dealer who has an ar-15
and kit they're chasing this guy they
grip him up they have him up on the hood
of a car
and then the question comes right you
know open your bag and and you know in
the back of my head i'm thinking
on who's authority right right on whose
authority do i open this force they
exert the authority of force that they
exert over others this is this is where
warlords come from this is lord of the
flies this is hobbs nasty life is nasty
british and short right you he wins
every time because they had to resort to
that immediately so there are a lot of
people who might say they're anarchists
or whatever they wear all black they go
and smash things but it's also important
to realize some of these people don't
have a political ideology you know we we
assume if they're there with antifa then
they must share their beliefs a lot of
them are just
smashing for the sake of smashing and if
you talk to them they won't tell they
won't understand any concept of of
political philosophy or any society so
we get into this a little bit in the
book as well and i talk about um
eric hoffer who's sort of the you know
the working-class philosopher of the
1950s he wrote this book called true
believers and he's talking about this
this situation you know it when you have
this sort of mass
of you know basically disenfranchised
youth uh typically male
who are denied meaningful work who are
denied meaningful access to society or
at least the perception of denied
meaningful access to society right you
get all these tensions that
will inherently bubble up and they will
go go into something and in some cases
they know it go they go into religion in
some cases they'll go into
uh you know this you know you could look
at stuff that's going on right now
obviously hopper didn't talk about this
but like keto or crossfit or some of
these different things but for other
people you know they want to just be the
guys who are going out drinking and then
getting into fights and so here's the
thing if you're looking at the situation
now and even you know not consciously
making this decision but if the media is
telling you well if you join this
drinking and fighting group you'll be
prosecuted but if you join this one
you'll be free to go celebrated
applauded and if something happens you
know you'll either get a slap on the
wrist or the charges will be dropped
which one are you going to join that's
why we see that there's that video out
of portland where some random kid runs
up and punts a guy in the head that kid
doesn't have a political ideology that
guy can't tell you anything about that's
from 2016 right no no no this was uh uh
the punt in the hat i think was 2018. oh
okay yeah i'm pretty sure it's 2018. a
guy is running from the group of antifa
and then he they push him he falls and
the kid runs up and then full just
punts his head
that kid doesn't believe anything most
of those people there the mob that
chases random people doesn't believe
anything so these are just useful idiots
just bodies for
authoritarian communists the people who
are willing to use violence to get their
way because i'll put it this way the
people you've you've met from antifa
on a polit on a political ideology do
they believe in respecting your right to
liberty
absolutely not right they believe that
they should dictate how you live and how
everyone else should live libertarian
left
hey man me and my friends are going to
do our thing and and cooperate and you
do your thing it doesn't scale you can't
have 10 000 no you can't but you can't
you can't have a free market a
libertarian right would can scale up
infinitely so this is this is the
problem that that lenin ran into in the
soviet union and you see i'm looking for
this bolshevik revolution i'm looking
for this worker revolution what is wrong
with these workers they're just not
revolting i don't understand why won't
these why do they just keep going to
their jobs and and working we need to
come up with
well perhaps you know the theory can't
be wrong it's just we're just missing an
element yes that's what it is we need a
you know a group to lead the workers yes
that's what it is and we'll call it the
of course the revolutionary vanguard
will be the and that'll be us of course
because we're not stuck in these menial
jobs while we will be the vanguard to to
lead the workers in their uprising again
to their best uses because we know
what's best for them that's and that's
len that's where that's where
it becomes goes from marxism to marxist
leninism so lenin adds this idea of the
vanguard of the proletariat and that
becomes the bolsheviks
let's talk about the the political
realities of these leftists did you see
that okay boomer girl apparently has a
two million dollar apartment in new york
doesn't surprise me so we actually have
a beautiful art just behind jack of okay
okay okay boomer girl it's a
nico right nico something yeah yeah
nicole yeah uh so this is art from g
prime
nika uh so this is joe biden as a
gigantic um junji ito style monster
eating okay boomer girl uh so she's this
wearing a shirt that says tax the rich
apparently she lives in a two million
dollar apartment congratulations on all
your wealth and success just don't
pretend that you're a leftist when you
are the bourgeoisie
the vanguard of the proliferation right
right we also have this story that i
want i want to break down
we're getting back to the good old days
jack where we used to make fun of aoc
all the time it was like she's the
biggest news right we have this story
from the daily mail quote sell your
seventy thousand dollar tesla critics
slam learjet liberal aoc for not helping
her grandmother after she posted photos
of her puerto rican home ravaged by
hurricane maria and blamed trump
so here's what we know about aoc first
first of all
i i am not happy to see that her
grandmother is living in in terrible
conditions because of the hurricane it
devastated puerto rico i'd love to be
able to to help out there's a lot of
people we should do like uh we should do
like a fun gift go for a gift go for
aoc's grandma her in in abuela right or
play in in puerto rico yeah i normally i
would say yes but i kind of agree with
the critics i'm not going to assume aoc
bought a tesla in cash people like
people seem to think that you know this
nico woman she has a two million dollar
apartment she doesn't have two million
dollars in cash she got a mortgage all
right so she puts down it's it still
means she probably had like 20 grand for
closing costs and if she put on like
five percent so she still has a lot of
cash oh yeah to buy it aoc probably put
it
down
no i mean right so aoc doesn't have 70
grand she probably put a down payment
she probably got a loan for the car
but she ain't doing too bad apparently
she lives in that really nice luxury uh
hotel in i'm sorry luxury apartment in
dc with an infinity pool we heard that
story so she's gonna she's gonna make
congressional salaries uh about 175 000
plus by the way you get per diem you get
mileage it's staff salaries you're
you're doing fine you're you're doing
very well i have to imagine she makes
money elsewhere
she's no i doubt she's just sitting on a
congress well and we already know though
that she did have that position with the
justice dems and there was that whole
sort of like
and this was actually when they got
investigated that's why they sort of
disbanded a lot of it because they were
trying to run a political committee and
a for-profit
uh firm but as both as the justice
department it was all feeding each other
it was almost laundering cash right so
it was like never accused aoc if
laundering cash that's
i say almost because i can't make that
official assessment because i don't know
but basically one company hires her
boyfriend right and then all of a sudden
he moves in with aoc in new york how
convenient yeah things like that but
this is the perfect example example of
it's it's not lib limousine liberal
they're calling her a leader jet labor
she's not a liberal she's a socialist
socialist what what what would we call
that what's an expensive thing that
starts with the letter s we can make a
champagne socialist
yeah that's a shock that one you get the
illiterate a little bit of a literature
close close
i should leave socialists
i don't drink but but total um
uh total shout out to rachel bovard
because i was i uh she gave a somali a
presentation uh some oh somalia
socialist maybe there you go
and i was i was enthralled she just knew
everything about it she's apparently was
on it for seven years and i don't drink
at all but totally not my thing but i
was just really interested in the
stories this is uh this is this is what
we consistently get i mean we had
limousine liberals for a long time the
people saying oh climate change and then
they fly in private jets so climate
change they buy beachfront property now
you get aoc saying like my poor
grandmother and it's like lady you got
money i'm not going to pretend aoc is
the one percentage this is this is a
barack obama's brother in in in africa
oh right right
yeah so this is this is the this is the
i guess the consistent uh message we
should expect from these leftists who
claim to want to fight for the working
class or tax the rich it's like dude
they're rich
do they think they're working class
like aoc when she's educated elite now
she's in congress yeah if you're i and
i'm i've this is actually something i
thought about a lot as i was so a lot of
the the book i i wrote like a year ago
so throughout 2020 i'm writing this
actually
yeah the end of the book but i get into
all this stuff i get into socialism
communism anarchism i get into all of it
right and i kind of just use antifa as
the touch point for all of it and
you know one and so i went back and i've
been i was like sort of speed reading it
you know just to refresh myself and
going through it and you know just
really thinking about this issue of the
working class and the people who claim
to represent the working class if you're
someone who claims to represent the
working class you're probably not
working class right it's it's like never
happened it's it is so incredibly rare
because people who are in working class
they're they're they're working they're
they've got their families they you know
uh you know they're busy they're they're
they're living paycheck to paycheck and
we want to
you know obviously we want to have a
system where people like that can have a
family and can have home ownership and
don't have to be in you know up to their
years in debt right but and they
shouldn't need these massive expansive
political movements claiming you know
some sort of agency of acting in their
benefit because you're just not you're
typically either you're either the new
poor or you're someone who's from that
sort of upper middle class band of well
i never really had any meaningful right
of passage so my you know finding myself
finding my knees on my my center finding
my center is going to be helping those
who are less fortunate that i they don't
know how to help themselves but i do
it's interesting how new classes emerge
right you had like the proletariat and
the bourgeoisie and then there's that
that painting i don't know if you've
ever seen it where it's like the workers
and then the police and then you know
it's like a layer then the politicians
are on top or whatever
you're the one where they're like
holding it up yeah yeah yeah i see that
so you have like aoc who is certainly
not the working class she is an educated
elite bourgeois she is wealthy by global
standards especially in a six-figure
salary nearly 200k plus probably she
makes money elsewhere she's probably
over 200 000 a year she's really close
to the one percent really close but
she's not i think one percent is up to
like 400 or something a thousand a year
to be one percent but she's well off
but the more the the uh
it's interesting that there's not just
the working class and the landlords
anymore or the merchant class then it's
all of a sudden there's like
there are middle class people who are
also landlords because they own a single
property and they rent out part of it
right so it's what ends up happening is
you get people like aoc who keep looking
up they see the ultra wealthy and they
say as long as i'm not them i'm the
working class
although i don't think aoc has ever
actually produced something
i think to be to be fair you know she's
now um
uh she's in her second term as a
congresswoman you don't expect a lot of
bills to get passed by someone who's you
know this just this new to the to
congress or anything but
what what is what has she actually given
to society that has helped you know you
know i'd love to see that
i i really do think that there's there's
sort of this struggle with aoc because
when she first ran she actually seemed
to be quite more populist than she has
when she's been in office you could
argue the same about trump by the way um
but you you wonder if there are issues
and i seem to remember there were a
couple times where her and like matt
gates might have you know tweets that
were both in support of the same thing
um in in some of these instances and you
wish that you could see stuff like that
going on where it's like hey we you know
completely disagree on you know maybe
this
aspect of foreign conflict or you know
certain climate change provisions or
actually i think it was climate change
actually it was a climate change thing
where where matt gates was on um and
you'd love to see something where these
these sort of this new generation of
culture warriors is actually finding
common ground
and you have to imagine that would
trickle down
to these device the divisive street
level of some of this stuff or the
divisive social media level or the
device of you know the school boards and
the facebook groups and everything else
where instead of it's oh i've got to
defeat you i've got to beat you i've got
my team has to win and so instead of
making a team sport out of it you say
hey we're all on the same team then
that's called you know it's kind of
cliche but that's the united states of
america we all live here
that's not true anymore can we do that
no i i understand you have a difference
of opinion no i read that article for
american greatness i disagree with it i
think it went a little far but
i mean republicans right now are paid to
sit on their hands and watch democrats
ravage the system
right so so even right now with the
conversation about conservatives using
the language of the left look at what
they're talking about the january 6th
commission republicans keep going
exactly where democrats want them to go
it reminds me of when i was younger i
was playing a game of chess
i was like 18 and i was playing just
this guy and he was laughing and he said
you can only move where i let you move
right and uh he was right he was better
at me better than me at chess and he
knew if i go here he'll he'll go here
because that's his best you know and
then he was he walked me into a
checkmate and then i you know had to
learn and get better at the game so you
look at what's happening right now
the left comes out and says january 6
insurrection meanwhile we had a year
plus two three four years of
anti-extremism i remember watching in
berkeley an old lady was was was
standing in a park in the uh uh was at
mlk park and samantha threw an m80 at
her and then she falls backwards someone
was probably like 60 70 years old
probably could have gotten really hurt
and i was like what is wrong with these
people
no commission no investigation not even
a commission on covid
but the dems come out and say january 6
commission and yet republicans do
no it's political republicans should do
blm commission anti-foot commission and
then when they say january 6 republicans
just do not respond at all in any
meaningful capacity at all like you
didn't even hear him say it watch jack
say january 6 commission right now
tim january 6th we should be
investigating antifa right now i want to
i want to get a bill on the table to
investigate antifa what do you say ian
you're here
all right
although the democrats wouldn't agree
stop walking into their room
it's like i'm watching what's going on
it's being on offense and defense right
it's it's one side is projecting the
other side is deflecting so the the
republicans and you've seen this again
and again with the republican party this
is my party right
where they will count it as a win
if they were able to stop the democrats
from doing x right whatever it is and
you see this interplay again and again
with the republican party well it's a
win because we stopped this the win
because we stopped that oh we you know
we couldn't get this to stop we couldn't
get this one through so that was right
no that's not a win right that's that's
that's stalemate that's neutral if
you're talking world war one trying to
work slow defeat they are going to win
eventually if you allow them to continue
to take over every single
institution of society every single
cultural outlet of society like has been
happening they are running the table
with this because they knew that their
policies if they came out and just told
you you know early on say back in the
1990s hey this is what we want this is
what we're going to do with america it
never would have flown in terms of
public opinion there's a this famous
quote from a great philosopher and he
said never fight an alligator underwater
oh
he was right
[Laughter]
ian said that yeah that's pretty good
i love it yeah i just came out of
nowhere and you're like wow that's a
good one
but yeah yeah don't do that no right
that's what republicans do they're going
into the territory of the democrats
thinking they're going to win it's like
bro you're on their home turf
you got to stand up for something and
talk about what the american people want
what your constituents want but
apparently i guess it wasn't wrong when
the democrats in the media were saying
republicans just want to own the libs so
what do they do they look they said they
say hey lib make an argument wrong your
argument about about the january 6
commission is wrong and then the whole
conversation the whole time that all
that anyone hears is storming the
capital right insurrection then you go
and ask a left it's about anti-fun they
go what what's antifa
because republicans don't talk about it
right so trump said this is why when
when joe biden comes out and says auntie
but that's just an idea right it's he's
setting the frame he's already setting
the frame of now you have to say antifa
is not an idea antifa is this this and
this and are they idea are they not able
they don't have an organization they
don't have a leader they don't have a
headquarters you see this on the
internet all the time every time i tweet
about antifa they say where's their
headquarters jack where's their oh fifa
you know where's the where's the
headquarters who's the leader who's the
organization do they have ranks they
needed the uniforms actually they do
have uniform i say well they have
university rights they have they have
logos they have flags they may not have
uh stated ranks but they do have a
hierarchy in terms of their you know red
green yellow in terms of the black
blocks so yeah they do actually have all
of these things it's it's quite simple
you know when a pit bull bites pitbull
doesn't let go
it has now been what are we going on
five months and the democrats will not
stop talking about january 6th and the
republicans how often have they brought
up minneapolis
never
one one thing we should actually throw
out you know today is actually the
anniversary of david doran right and i i
did not see and i you know maybe i just
didn't see it but i don't remember any
of republican leadership or uh anyone
who's been on the sort of you know quote
unquote black the blue side say anything
about that you know i i ran the
fundraiser for his family when that took
place you know we did all we did
everything for that and this was not
something where you you had anybody
today's the one year anniversary but
when it was the one year anniversary of
george floyd that's the only thing the
democrats they flew they flew the black
lives matter flags at embassies
celebrations the story we had out on
human events and the story of david dorn
is that he was a retired police captain
who heard an alarm go off at his
friend's store and went to go check it
out and someone put a bullet in his
chest yeah i wanted to steal a tv and
the film is brutal the live stream it
live stream so he yeah he he he ends up
dying on facebook live and a guy was
like a guy's yelling like all that for a
tv man
meanwhile you get the complicated story
of george floyd which is
complicated at the very
in the in the best case it's it's
absolutely hard to break through david
dorn was a good guy
a model citizen someone we could look up
to and when that you know and i i did
get the opportunity to speak with his
wife early on and made sure that you
know we had her blessing obviously
before we did the fundraiser so it
sparked her at length um before she came
out and spoke at some of the conventions
and and did some of the advocacy work
that she's done which has been fantastic
but you know she told us these stories
that
you know he would go out and he would
drive by the shop every once in a while
one of the reasons
that
he cared about the shop so much that's
actually the place that it had been on
his beat when he was when he was a
patrol officer and so he had responded
the things there in the past it had been
something that he just sort of came up
with in st louis and that's actually the
shop they run a jewelry shop there as
well that's where he got the engagement
ring for his wife you know what it's not
just uh it's it's not just the
republican politicians look at what the
left does for george floyd look at what
the the corporations do for george floyd
the republicans should be
should be passing a bill saying today
should be david dornday they should be
putting up david dorn flags they should
be they should be doing everything and
more the left has done for george floyd
but for for david doran the problem is
the anvil is not hot for them so if they
try to mimic it's kind of like
the the democrats whoever are shooting
downhill if they try that same tactic no
no
it's not about mimicking them it's about
making your own space creating your own
culture making making and saying you
know what democrats if you don't want to
be involved in the conversation we don't
care because we respect david dorn and
we're sad for his loss the problem is
it's the media that's heating up the
whole um
chauvin you know so ignore them
conservative media keeps responding to
the left's narrative the media comes out
and says here's our story and the
conservatives then respond to instead of
doing their own work but for in order
for the the
republican politicians to get that done
they would need media presence that
would be like david dorn david no they
wouldn't remember david dornan people
would win that being said though
you know the question i think we're
really talking about is critical mass
right and i think that at this point
there is enough of a critical mass of
independent media which thrives through
social media like this podcast right
here where you do now have this separate
space which you can inject these
cultural
stories these icons david doran isn't it
is a a cultural icon we got a picture of
him and
for you know i actually saw that
someone drew it for us
and that's that as someone who was
and everyone who spoke about him a
pillar of his community you know got
people off the street in some cases got
them into the police force served the
community that's all he wanted to do
that was his whole life right um didn't
didn't even wake his wife up when he
when he went out that night because he
knew what was going on in st louis and
he knew she probably would have said
don't go and he knew he was going to go
anyway right this this is the type of
per that's the type of hero right that
that i want to teach my boys about that
i want to teach my kids about you know
you look at david doran this is a guy
who's a hero right not not lebron james
not you know some of these other
celebrities who are out there shooting
their mouth off about stuff that they've
never even looked into right someone who
serves their community who serves others
and in this case made the ultimate
sacrifice that's a hero think about
david dorn's behavior
the left is angry about police they say
are are brutal or too scared david dorn
was a police officer he retired and when
he went to that pawn shop did he show up
shaking and quiving with a gun shooting
wildly at civilians or whatever like the
left would claim the cops do no no so he
certainly seemed like he was a good cop
because when he went to this pawn shop
he didn't go in guns ablaze and he
wasn't freaking out and he lost his life
because someone thought the tv was more
valuable so there there's every reason
this man should be celebrated by the
left but they don't care
and i think conservatives by the way
working class yeah absolutely yeah i i
think too many conservatives have made
the mistake of assuming that the left
operates on the same moral foundation in
the world framework as they do and that
a sound argument will resonate with
these people no either they don't care
they relish in the destruction or they
just want power
so when someone like david dorn loses
their life oh they're not going to say
two words about it
when the republicans do what does the
media say they're just trying to to own
the libs by by doing the same thing and
it's not the same thing we're talking
about a system and blah blah blah right
but so when you're talking about and
this isn't necessarily a moral question
in this case but we're talking about the
framework of these things and critical
mass to take it back to the original
story that we spoke about at the top of
this the lab leak theory right this was
something where we were told very early
on you can't talk about this this is
debunked this is not real this is not a
thing and yet there was a cadre of
independent media that never let go of
this they were a pit bull when it came
to that story they didn't let go of it
and it finally broke through because
enough people sat down and a lot of it
has to do with you know there's all
these sort of like you know think pieces
now well you know it really is
interesting that it came around at this
point it's almost like something
happened and going from 2020 into 2021
that we can now talk about it right it
is clear like trump isn't around anymore
and this was this was the pro-trump you
know kind of stance at the time
that he took and you just didn't want to
say trump was right that's the reason
people are talking about it now but it's
also because so many people for the past
year and a half would not let this go
they knew the facts were on their side
and they were a thorn in the side of
this narrative all the way through to
the point where of course it broke
through and that's why you're seeing now
even in public opinion polls you're
seeing it spiking high 40s almost 50
percent are saying look i think this
came out of that lab
yeah there was it was a medium article
that started reigniting the the the um
this is nicholas wade so there's a
former the former new york times
scientist couldn't even get in the
mainstream press had to write it on
medium and then finally it breaks
through but it it it is absolutely uh i
i do think the work of buzzfeed
contributed i think they knew the foyers
were coming you know um the the fauci
did and the government did and many of
the journalists were like
these emails are going to get really
sooner or later and i wonder if they
were like we'll release them and what
does buzzfeed do totally positive
narrative fauci was just fighting to
keep you know give us a sound you know
keep controlled situation and then you
read the emails and you're like this is
crazy but the media's framing of it cnn
wapo and and buzzfeed here's the emails
leaked and fouchy is a great and good
man so here's here's the real question
and this gets back to the other american
greatness article you were talking about
if we have so the divisions in america
yes there's there's an urban royal rural
division i can't talk anymore for some
reason
i'm i'm i'm out here talking in
different ways
but
so we now have a division that can be
neighbor to neighbor right
that it doesn't necessarily matter where
you are it matters who you're listening
to what you're listening to
bro bro down the street there's two
houses yeah one that's all rainbows and
one that's all trump oh nice next door
to each other actually with each other
yeah and that's you know and that gets
that reminds me of these these stories
that you hear about when from the civil
war and they talk about you know brother
versus brother father versus son and you
think like well i would i would never
turn against my brother's my brother i
would never return against my father's
you know we made this agreement or turn
against him and then you sort of look at
some of these divisions now and you say
and and the look at the way that
families have split up over this stuff i
um
i'll just say it right i had people that
did in my family that didn't want to
come to my wedding because they were
convinced they were convinced that the
woman i was marrying was a russian spy
because she was born in the soviet union
not not even russia phobia one of the
former you know the former satellite
countries they would call them now but
they were convinced because they are
msnbc watchers and they are convinced
that that's that's that's what was going
on here's this trump guy and this
immigrant girl from the wrong part of
the world and well
she must be you know she must be one of
them and
i don't say that to like own them or
anything that's sad i just think i think
the whole situation is that i i'd rather
have politics be put
aside and i just like to have my family
back right you know yeah we can talk
about star wars or something or whatever
the latest superman movie is like
batman vs robin which is quite good
actually
well we should take super chats if you
haven't already give a little tap to
that like button it really helps out
share the show with your friends and
people you know if you think we do a
good job
if uh if you look at the ratings of cnn
on youtube with hundreds of millions and
you're like i like that cnn has more
views than than tim cast irl and other
shows like including crowder and
stick sex and hammer uh then by all
means don't share and then you can you
know watch cnn and have a good time but
if you think
that we should get more views then we'll
need your help but let's read some super
chats and if you want to get your super
chats in now it's time we're gonna start
reading them we got dc pagan says rand
paul 2024 libertarians must take over
the republican party yeah what do you
think about that you like rand uh i i
like graham but i don't think the
libertarians are going to take over them
that's not going to happen no uh dave
smith's cool people are like i like this
is a great guy they're truly running i
don't think so no no i think i think
it's well he's babbling v so i think
that's like uh that's like a smith
or no no i think it's something dave um
no i i think uh i think basically that
the constituency for the libertarian
party isn't quite what they think it is
in terms of voting blocks well you've
seen the meme but the fox it's like the
very beautiful fox's libertarian ideas
and then the scraggly yeah right right
right
so you know gary johnson
you know i think you know whenever we we
mock politicians on this show and we're
like you know one one one joke i made
was like a new project for elon a new
form of government it's called marsism
it's where you take all of the people as
soon as they get elected and put them on
the spaceship and then send in mars
and that's it that's literally how the
government works i'm fine with that and
then they're just gone
never hear from again um but we're like
oh rand paul can stay no i know rand
paul he can stay no i got it and and you
know i know i'm hard on my libertarians
but i i will throw this out there that
libertarian you're so good on foreign
policy you guys are just so good on that
i love you yeah
there's a lot of republicans who aren't
and a lot of neocons who decided it's
better to be a democrat because uh
because you were going to lose your war
by voting for a a anti-war republican
right isn't that funny that you had a
bunch of these uh these these
neoconservatives who are like all of
these policies literally everything
pro-life not worth it for me i just want
to blow people up in the middle east so
i'll be a democrat instead yeah sounds
like they didn't have a whole lot of
principles to begin with
all right cristiano says hey bruv not
one to defend biden but checked footage
and it seems like the unknown soldier
ceremony is a change in procedure last
year during both memorial and veterans
day trump did the same thing all right
well there you go
what was that story i mean where the
biden didn't lay the wreath they changed
it i guess people were saying it was
changed for covid but i'm like why would
they keep doing it if they're not
wearing masks in the procedure but you
know we'll uh we'll we'll talk about a
lot of stuff in the bonus segment so
make sure you sign up for timcast.com
bonus segment comes up around 11 or so
make 1984 fiction again says this
episode uh this episode this is my 10
bribe to be the first on the list for
tim cast bumper stickers also how do i
get a don't fight with an alligator
underwater mug go to timcast.com click
store and the mug is there and you can
get it and it's it's the meme of uh it's
the drake meme but it's ian instead and
he's like alligators underwater and then
alligators on land nice yeah
you so you would fight them on land i
didn't say that
i just said don't fight them under water
because even then it's still not
probably a great idea not ideal
i hear all right maybe you punch him in
the nose or something
omg puppy says jack who do you think is
behind the demoralization and
destabilization of western societies
active measures by foreign enemies soros
davos technocrats domestic leftists
media outrage for profit
also i mean you you've got to look at
the above you know right you've got to
look at the sort of like the situation
as it is or as it was towards the end of
the cold war i mean america was the
hegemon america was the great power in
the world and so the question is if
you're someone who wants power you know
and power it becomes a zero-sum game if
you're in that sort of real politic
environment then you've got to take it
from someone and if that's western
civilization then that's your target
right on
all right k marie says tim cast is the
new punk rock what happened to feel the
rage of a new generation
eric a says jack this is the most
important question of the night how can
i get your comic book
uh we still have the comic book up it is
at iconic comics.com i'm also actually
gonna be doing my first uh comic con
coming up this summer so we're actually
going down to texas for that i think
it's temple texas we're doing it uh in
august so super excited um my comic is
up there iconic comics we have some i
believe we have some autographed copies
available there um go get the agent
posto it's kind of based on my life but
like a very you know stylized version of
it with my wife and my son and and some
of my cast of characters because
andrew's
right yeah and you have this weird
silencer suppressor on your on your gun
that makes sense oh man
all the gun guys all the gun guys hit me
i didn't draw it
it's a weird thing it's cool whatever uh
did you hear about that punk band that's
charging a thousand dollars
unless you're vaccinated that's 18
so there's a funny story the least punk
thing i've ever heard about yeah it's
like super pro big pharma super pro
establishment and super pro rich people
if you're rich you're you get to i still
remember i still remember you know
showing my age maybe a little bit but
when green day went and performed i
remember with like a john kerry thing
yeah
in 2004
and i was like
i was like what like
yeah i don't want to be an american
political at all dude they performed in
94 94 and i think their tickets were
five bucks do you remember that i saw
them in 94. so i showed you something
green
it gets better
one of the fans i was super young i was
super young sure one of the 94 95 one of
those one of the fans of this band
teenage bottle rocket apparently wasn't
able to get the vaccine because she had
just had coveted and so the doctor told
her it's too soon you're not gonna be
able to get it and so she's like so now
i literally don't get to see the show
that's right if you're a poor person who
was told by your doctor the vaccine you
can't get it for some medical reason
and uh you want to go to the show you'll
be able to but i can assure you the rich
people won't care and won't think twice
if they really want to go to that show
not that they probably would but if they
chose to
i think people should i think you know
if there are rich people out there go do
it the vanguard of the working class the
vanguard all right this one's serious
adam austin says tim i'm an electrician
in northeast ohio copper prices aren't
being talked about our wire went up
almost 300 percent since january wire
that was 67 dollars is now almost 140
wow whoa
early last year ian was like dude you
got to buy a bunch of copper and i'm
talking a bunch like hundreds it's like
mostly worthless of it mostly up 300
percent so whatever you put into it
you're going to see so i bought a bunch
of copper it's actually worth it's value
you buy it by the ream or the or is it
by the spool bars i like ingots
personally
um but you can make wiring out of it i
mean right yeah shell casing you know i
got it because we have a little forge
for like making things for fun so i was
like it's probably the best medal for
that but it's metal and it's cheap and
ian was like i should buy it so i just
bought some
so cheap got copper bars
they're like it's really cool actually
there's like it was not a precious metal
when you bought it but now it is yeah i
mean it is it kind of uh there's like
dollars it's like an america it's like
it's like it's like a us dollar but it's
just copper imprint that's pretty cool
it looks pretty cool yeah and it's like
it's worthless so you're counterfeiting
copper money no no you buy it from like
oh yeah no no of course not yeah if it
was rare i think it would be as valuable
as gold it was the rarest gold yeah
maybe if he's like he's like we've got
this printing press out back
special ink
people keep saying alex jones was right
again yeah
i remember when when when like a jar
right the jar didn't joe rogan say like
people oh alex jones an apology like a
while ago yeah
yeah it was because we i mentioned this
before when we had him on the show he
told me that a lot of the meat we eat is
cloned and i'm like no we're not eating
cloned beef alex that's crazy i remember
this google it i'm like dude we're
eating clown people so this is didn't
this come out with was it salmon is it
salmon is the new one
it's um it's it's like lab grown i want
to say it's salmon it could be something
else but and it's and the the new one i
remember it's and it won't be labeled so
you won't know oh wow yeah
how crazy would it be if like literally
alex jones was never wrong and we
actually lived in that crazy of a
reality of all the cr interdimensional
aliens and cell towers and chimeras or
whatever did you see was it didn't
someone try banning human chimera
research and the democrats said like
yeah we're good we're gonna do it really
yeah what was that that was that in the
voucher leagues too no no no it was it
was like a normal voting session and
they were like so-and-so's amendment to
ban human animal chimera research
no
because
this is when they were doing the voice
votes a couple weeks ago yeah it was a
lot yeah there were a few of those and
they they did actually say in those
voice votes there was a there was an
amendment um i figured if it was rans or
not but to to shut down um research at
the one in super virology yes yeah that
one passed yeah
all right let's uh let's grab some super
chits
david emmen says i teased jack about
overusing the phrase breaking news and
he blocked me on twitter i miss his
tweets is that true
um no that's not true i don't know you
overuse that phrase
all right nathan snyder says there was a
recent study that give me give me his
account i'll take care of it says david
m
i don't know i will
yeah just remember that one we'll take
care of it afterwards nathan snyder says
there was a recent study that showed the
effectiveness of masks at protecting the
wearer in a low uh low viron environment
masks are effective but in a high
vibrant environment masks offer no
protection yeah there was something that
came out that said um indoors the air
circulates so much that after a certain
amount of time it becomes less and less
effective
so that was a huge problem
that you like we learn new stuff every
day i think it's fair to say you know a
lot of people are saying like fauci was
saying don't wear masks and i'm like
there's an email where fauci says he
advises someone not to wear a mask and
i'm like right and then a month later he
literally did the exact same thing on 60
minutes right identical this this is
essentially concurrent yeah yeah so it's
it's it's
people think he was secretly changing
his opinion no no he was public about
being wrong and flip-flopping what gets
me is the people that i see just out in
public outside by themselves wearing a
mask
protecting the environment brook o says
tim has the best uh tim as the best at
impressions
i think you're saying i'm the best at
impressions and that's true i am
but uh but jack's got a good stewie
griffin so you know stewie griffin's
already there's a few different ones in
there but you know that was the one i
just repeated what it was yeah i don't
even know what you're talking about the
air chad you're stewie's good you're
peter yeah
peter's as good as the you know it's as
good as this but it's kind of weird
because stewie and peter are both seth
macfarlane dude i actually got to see
family guy live once and they did it in
new york in broadway yeah and so i got
to see him doing a table read of this uh
the whole cast was there but when you
see him do it live you're like this guy
has like split personalities or
something
because he's he's holding the
conversations with himself in real time
and it's it's wild it's absolutely wild
someone gave us a whole bunch of banana
emojis yes wow yeah what's up with the
bananas gorillas
apes together
together strong no but this week it's
apes okay amc 8. shout out to a shout
out to the amc army online what's that
what's the diamond hand can hit 74 i
think or what 72. i think it's a little
check it right now i think it's i i so i
got i know there's after hours i got
lettuce hands you got lettuce hands what
does that mean i'm out banana hands
well you won banana ham 68 right now 68
right now 68 68 but it hit yeah it looks
like a hit about 72 1.7 and i think i
think it's going to go way up but they
keep saying it's they keep saying
you know not the squeeze not the squeeze
tim's not diamond hands tim is not
diving here
you know i'm looking at them folks
they're not diamonds at all nope i just
didn't know i didn't want to like i
didn't buy them before like when when
the memes where did you get in where did
you get in just like a couple days ago
okay no i think literally yesterday but
you didn't get in back in january a
bunch of people i had like a little bit
okay you know uh like very very little
bit yeah like 10. i get in like two
weeks ago when it was like 14. yeah and
then just like the today i'm still in
folks i'm still in we gotta do it i
didn't i didn't feel comfortable
constantly talking about it rising and
also holding stuff because i'm like what
do i do hold it till it's zero or i was
like i don't i don't i don't want to
have it i didn't buy any game stop
either for this reason and make it i get
stronger i hadn't bought yeah i hadn't
bought gamestop but this one this one
i've gotten so i'm writing i i just kind
of felt like now i'm gonna i'm not gonna
do this so i sold it because you want to
report on it without being on one side
or the other i didn't want it to get to
300 with me constantly talking about it
and then people would be like he's doing
it
right right got it yeah but i still did
like when it was started jumping up
really high i was like
we got to get a picture of tim all like
nah with lettuce
with the lettuce yeah he's just like
lettuce peanut butter i love lettuce
hands because someone was making fun of
david portnoy and i like poor noise cool
but someone mentioned how he sold his
meme stocks and they called them lettuce
hands right it was on a hotep i think
and i thought it was funny lettuce it's
worse than paper it's really worse yeah
the lightest sands
but it's so visual i love that i love
the visuals you know you know what i'm
you know i did though um uh i invested
in um graphene production okay companies
that produce graphene ooh and this will
help with the counterfeit press i mean
before no no no no just just ian won't
stop talking about it so it's like i'll
just do some stuff this is what's going
to really
are you familiar with graphene as a
material uh i
enlighten me it's a single layer of
atomic carbon so just a flat layer
hexagonally latticed if you look at it
it's like it looks like a honeycomb sure
and it's a more conductive than copper
it's stronger than steel it's more
deformable than paper you can make like
touch screen it's a super conductor and
a capacitor as well so it can be like a
battery and a wire all at once you could
make like touch screen wallpaper you can
make clothing out of it that's like
touch screen um you can still eat it you
can allow it with so many things
it's not too hard to make it's just that
we have to build the facilities to make
it so once so i look at these some of
these companies and they've been going
up in value the ones that produce
graphene production once we get to the
mass production level it's going to
start revolutionizing tons of
electronics and tons of stuff we make
and then i think these companies will
skyrocket and value the more gets
heavily adopted so it's like a
it's like a snowball rolling down a hill
right if you build it they will come
once the factories exist and they can
make it cheap cheap enough everyone's
going to want to use it which is going
to make the factories expand and grow
and scale schools go yeah yeah so the
meme stocks
it's fun but i'm kind of like i want to
invest something that makes me feel good
that's tangible you know i could
appreciate that which is dogecoin so i
bought a bunch of things
right
all right orwell was a prophet 1984 says
for service guarantees citizenship how
about a net one dollar taxes paid
threshold to vote if you annually paid
5k in taxes but receive 5001 in
government programs you can't vote just
one dollar net paid hell i'd be okay
with one cent desantis paul 2024
it's not a bad idea if you're on the
receiving end of welfare than you
abstain
and if you're on the producing end of
welfare then you get about the price
it's not perfect people that are born
into poverty and people are born into
wealth i hate that that i i hate that
family wealth is passed down i mean
think about it this way this is clever
though listen
if the people who are paying taxes
let's say you're born poor right
and so your family receives some kind of
benefit
then the rich people who are paying
taxes say we're tired of paying all of
these poor people we're giving money to
the government it's going to them and
they're lazy so then guess what happens
because you can't vote they all vote and
they strip away your welfare benefits
well guess what no you can vote now you
can vote
i think it's going to make a lot of
angry votes i think we need i think what
we need is a vanguard of the working
class
and the vanguard
will drive them we'll drive them into
the promised land yes
yeah that's right milk and honey i could
see it milk and honey nolan bus says
will you please have steve bannon on
uh i think we could we could we could
muster that if uh yeah if we could you
know steve bannon right i i could ask
him it's it's hard steve doesn't want to
go to anything he's like he's like a
recluse
he's like a recluse though he doesn't
want he does not leave
the you know the bannon town house he
does not like
nice it's it's you know this is the same
thing every once in a while will but
it's like very
you know specific reasons same thing
with crowder and a bunch of other
personalities i'm like why would they
leave their own show which is wildly
popular to come and do my show you know
it doesn't make a lot of sense people
who are consistently running a podcast
have less of a reason to leave their
podcast for somebody else you know
yeah it's it's i don't know i mean
limited circumstances i can i can run it
by it
well you know we'll see whatever yeah
i'm not i'm not gonna cry about it
like uh people were like get crowder on
and you know i'm just like crowder's not
gonna fly out here he's like he's doing
a show he's doing a big show it's way
bigger than this one yeah he'd be doing
me a favor if he did that'd be great hey
shut up hey buddy shutting down your
company for a day or so just to come out
and help mike that's the thing too is
like people don't realize that you know
when you get to a certain point that you
you're just constantly being pulled in
different directions like you know even
for me it's like you know and
time is a finite resource right so you
know the time you're putting into this
means like like for me it's like hey
this is the night that i didn't get to
see my kids very much right i spent the
whole day with him which is great but
it's like that's you know is it worth it
i say you know what tim i haven't done a
couple months let's go come out and do
it we've got the book we're doing human
events now so let's do it but at the
same time when you're when you're
running operations of something like
abandoned or a crowder etc you know
you're constantly churning you're
constantly churning stuff out or you're
like fouchy who's just so
you know he's he's responding in emails
all he does apparently is he's
funny emails oh gee
all right let's see
liberty or death says before covet and
chas there were frequent rumors of
mysterious trucks driven by racist
people running around seattle attacking
people then a truck flees into jazz and
a teenager ends up dead
because they whip up these lies to
recruit people
you tell a lie for a few months about
crazy cars then once everyone's heard
about it you go join us to defend
against these car you've heard about the
cars right no i mean i heard about that
i know about the shooting i mean like
someone is someone makes up the rumor
i'm saying hypothetically right you
start a rumor you wait a month then you
go up to someone say you heard about
those cars right those racists yeah
that's bad right yeah help us stop them
you see what i mean
we have to stop the cars you make the
rumor and then you recruit off it a
month later yeah obviously
all right
daniel welch says tim i have to correct
you you keep saying beef is bad for the
environment please get someone who knows
regenerative agriculture to talk about
food systems or watch sacred cow on
amazon grasslands can store huge amounts
of carbon that is true
yeah i think the problem is factory
farming for the most part so michael
shellenberger talks about this in in his
book i don't know and he'd be something
great for you guys to have on if you
haven't um yet and his book is fantastic
and he's he writes it from the
perspective of an environmentalist but
something he talks about in terms of the
environment is that the if we make
better processes for
uh cattle like we're not going to stop
raising cattle right yeah it's just
something as a civilization we've been
doing for you know arguably 5 000 plus
years right uh you know husbandry
agriculture that being said the more
efficient we make these processes the
better it is for the environment yeah
red number two says true anarchists want
to be able to own machine guns engage in
consensual transactions and be left the
hell alone by the state antifa are just
a bunch of posers that is true but how
can you own anything if there is no
authority you you can't aggress against
another person but like who are you to
say that it belongs to you that's only
because the authority says it's yours so
in a left anarchist vision everyone
agrees to
arbitration so you have let's say let's
say in their utopian vision of a society
there's no authority it's just literally
if there's a river and people are
disputing what can go into it all of the
people with a stake in it have to sit
down in a big circle and do jazz hands
to discuss so someone says i'd like to
to speak please um i believe that the
river would be best accommodated blah
blah blah blah and then someone else
back i disagree and then everyone votes
so it's a vote comes down to a vote yeah
denmark denmark and then no denmark
would be a random representative
democracy democracy so it's it's
democratic but uh it ultimately in many
of the situations where anarchists have
tried it has to be unanimous well so
this is something similar to what
they're actually trying to push in
rojava in that northeast syria uh sort
of quadrant where they call it
democratic confederalism and that's the
idea is that it's sort of like these
local councils that are set up but then
they have a lot of this like ultimate
authority and there is no there's no
like higher let's see that's the
commission that they go to this is the
problem obviously if you have a large
swath of land there's no way to have a
meeting of you know a hundred thousand
people all doing jazz hands to figure
out what they like or they don't like
when you have 10 people consensus is not
hard
however with occupy wall street when
it's scaled up to even a few hundred
people the whole thing broke i'll give
you an example it's hilarious
the sanitation working group the people
who cleaned the crap at occupy said we
need bins
for storing things when it rains
otherwise everything gets soggy and
dirty
so they said i propose is the working
group sanitation working group that the
you know the the funds that we have from
the donations be used to buy us a set of
bins
someone then said i i object
this is wasteful
we can't use plastics it's destroying
the planet someone that said compromise
what if we do
recycled plastics so now we're taking
them out of the dump and putting them to
good use
someone else then said but they're not
being produced fairly so if we buy the
recycled ones we're still propping up
unfair trade practices so then they said
okay
here's the compromise we need fair trade
recycled plastic bins
bought on a secondary market not from a
major store or a chain or corporation
and so they went agreed and then the
executive the the facilitators went to
walmart and bought bins huh because you
can't do that how are you supposed to
find them where are they going to find
these magical bins that check every
little box it's impossible right so so
what was happening was at the level that
they had a few hundred people
and everyone had a complaint right so if
you have 10 people and someone's like i
propose that for dinner we have uh um
fried rice and someone else says i'm not
in the mood for rice it makes me gassy i
want uh uh fried vegetables
well then a consensus is not hard to
come by with only 10 people eventually
someone says okay how about we do
noodles instead with fried vegetables
this is like what you know what pizza
toppings yeah exactly like the classic
and then people are just like okay we'll
do half pepperoni half mushroom done
we're good right consensus you're not
gonna get there with a hundred thousand
people it's not gonna happen so your
your lefty energy is very difficult to
scale however right anarchy is
i've got a bunch of valuable things that
i'm willing to trade in exchange to make
you agree with me and give me what i
want yeah this is like galz gulch yeah
and so then you know ian's like i don't
want gluten-free pizza and i say ian i
will give you a bottle of water if you
agree with me on this one and ian says
bottle of water works for me
but the problem is if you come in with
all these like gems and bobbles and
you're like and then i i take a few for
myself and say hey look i have some gems
and bobbles i'm going to sell your these
are my gems and bobbles so that means
you aggressed against me and i'm but how
can you prove that
i can just under under these likes so in
right anarchy they do believe in
property rights right right so property
rights
i can defend my property from you as the
aggressor against me who who enforces
that i don't in an anarchy but what if
what if like how what if what if you
look out of out of sync what if they
believe me and then doesn't matter
i don't know man leave arbitration up to
the barrel to the gun it doesn't make a
lot of there's a lot of problems with it
but ultimately it's don't aggress
against other people so again i'm not an
anarchist i think there's it's a bit too
utopian and i think which would what are
you in saying though is that that's what
it would come down to ready it would
come down to people just saying you know
what i'm saying yeah it's going to come
down to shootouts and that's what leads
to warlords and that would slip right
what you do this is why that's why no
country in the world has ever tried this
yeah i think one of the biggest problems
with with uh with end caps is the rise
of monopolistic powers what would happen
if we had five competing
private private police forces
you know bought up one by one well so i
i call my private police force on ian
because i claim he stole bro the citizen
app was talking about this yes did you
see this
so the citizen app was talking about
having this so you know citizen app
right no so certain cities oh you don't
know okay
um yeah so some cities have this where i
don't recall if dc has it yet or not but
big cities and it's it's just it's the
idea of taking those um
like police ban radios and creating an
app that basically recreates that but
it's something where hey you know it's
almost like in in the waze you know
traffic app wherever i saw this crash
well instead of that it's hey i saw a
break-in hey i saw some crime i saw this
you know and sort of next door you know
kind of has this similar as well so
citizen is an app where you were allowed
to post all of those things as a
quote-unquote good citizen well they
were going to take that to the next
level and i believe they scuttled the
plans but they were talking about doing
a private dispatched police force that
you could actually call out through the
app if you're the victim of a crime
instead of calling the police
so so here's what happens
into a fight into it so i call my
private police force we'll call it uh
mick police and then ian calls uh his
police which is like police king yeah
yeah police
and then i'm like he's aggressing on my
property and then ian since it's my
property and then both our police forces
point guns at each other and then
they're like well we're now property of
kentucky fried police
so we're not wasn't able to fight each
other at all you know there's a there's
an end kappa stand meme so in kappa
stand of course is where the caps live
and there's a meme of this where um
yeah where it's it's uh uh we will we
are our if you join this new bank we
will provide you cover fire as you go to
your atm
free of charge i love it all right tommy
tampins says
tim i think the word you are looking for
is silver spoon socialist
they get the spoon from the government
they run
brian cox says ian for president 2024
build back with graphene
i think we can make it happen yes dale
spot says need to make quote who is
david dorn t-shirts and get them out
there that's not bad yeah then people
would be like who is david dorn right
exactly fish and pop says aoc is a
starbucks socialist i had a carpool
buddy that used to call herself a
starbucks hippie
so not
sure
but that's they they always try to claim
to be right yeah
all right
this uh
so so you know people think they can get
me the first few times they were able to
do it i'm going to read the super chat
anyway okay before you do can i shout
out michael knowles new book yes
speechless uh speechless
yeah controlling words controlling minds
okay i'm sorry but continue with the
super chat okay so jason q2 says i'm
speechless that jack bought michael
malus's new book speaking of speechless
you know what else is speechless michael
knowles books speechless controlling
words controlling minds available now
michael knowles turned book promo into a
meme amazing so that's what i've done
with um if you follow my twitter lately
i've been doing the my pillow promos
yeah right right right so you know promo
code so so it's andy i bought the
slippers any oh do you like the slippers
i got half off are they the best
slippers you've ever seen they're
amazing slippers they actually are
really good slippers yeah i was
seriously impressed i thought they'd be
all right but they're like no
yeah that's actually one of the main you
know comments i get from people is they
say they they get the stuff and like i'm
not doing the poem right now whatever
but it's like
um they'll say you know i bought
something because i like you know i like
these i feel like he's a patriot i like
his story like his christianity
whichever it is i like that effect you
know he's taking the stand for you know
for the right reasons i think and they
go wow these are really good products
actually i i really like these pillows i
like this like so what i've done with
the meme is that i've i've converted
like every
you know like mia khalifa tried to dunk
on me yesterday and i converted that
into like my pillow promo
i said having a rough week
if you want the best sleep i saw one of
you
so
you convert everything or breaking news
whatever it is i think you posted about
the slippers
and then i realized i was like i don't
have any slippers for like if i have to
walk out to the mailbox or something you
know i just yeah you don't want to put
shoes on if you're going out for a
minute you want my slippers right
obviously and then i was like i wonder
how much it'll cost and i went to the
site i typed in poso and i was like
that's not bad
it's like you know what i want a quality
pair of slippers i'm gonna have to get
some now you're making bank off of
meming that's the secret the meme
economy is right so uh there are three
books people need to buy
and t foodbook.com
michael malus's book as well speechless
and excuse me
and so we should uh antifablook.com is
that out right now that is out right now
burning up the charts should be number
one on amazon oh yeah let's do it
number uno so uh with that being said
make sure you follow us on facebook and
instagram while you can at tim cast irl
you can help share our videos uh you can
smash the like button if you haven't
already become a member at timcast.com
because we're gonna have a fun silly
this it's called the secret war
conspiracy theory and we're gonna talk
about it and it's just really really
silly we can't talk about it on youtube
though because youtube's boring but
we're gonna have fun that's what we do
we have fun at timcast.com you'll enjoy
this so uh just subscribe to the channel
share it with your friends and uh you
can follow me personally at tim cast we
mentioned your book but shout it out
again jack and it's antifa stories from
inside the black block antifablook.com
you guys can check it out if you don't
want to go to amazon we've got a bunch
of places where you can find it but you
can also find on amazon as well and
let's let's get uh that book should be
number one on amazon you know why why
well first of all it helps support your
work and you can keep doing reporting on
things like this like
but more importantly then regular people
who don't normally hear about this will
go on amazon look for a book and they'll
see number one antifa book and they'll
say i wonder what that is one thing that
that we actually did do in the book that
a lot of people said they like is that i
actually put out a timeline of the
summer of violence of 2020 every single
incident date time location this
happened this was the outcome so when
people say oh they weren't that bad
boom this is what happened there boom
this is what happened there boom you and
you got the whole thing right but you
know that number one spot is it's for
advertising
yes it is so regular people just be like
i've not heard this and they'll look
into it and maybe they'll buy it maybe
go whoa
and that's just more ways to spread the
message and get the word about what's
going on were you documenting your time
inside the chas oh there's a whole
chapter on it there's a whole chapter on
chaz you know it's and it's it's very
you know sort of like cinema veritas
where uh the first thing i noticed was
the smell
cal anderson park and i saw i saw spray
paint that said no gods no masters and i
knew that i had left the united states
oh snap i should read the audiobook i
haven't recorded the audiobook
i'll do one version like normal and do
another version like that
the george goodall uh ripoff version you
want to shout out yourself your twitter
or whatever are you yeah twitter is at
jackpotsobic um now the senior editor of
human events so go to human events check
it out for your greatest news analysis
and
uh dissident op-eds before they ban us
so check that out there as well as
instagram um you know don't have the
rumble up yet but maybe at some point we
will nice dude all right well you guys
can follow me ian crossland.net and uh
at ian crossland on social media you can
also check us on my music on uh amazon
music and spotify itunes happy to have
you guys always happy to see people like
jack succeeding always happy to get his
input on the show you guys can follow me
on twitter at sourpatchlids i have a
quest to have more followers and sour
patch kids and i'm getting closer i'm
closing in on them so please go follow
me there it's fun what is the secret war
conspiracy theory probably a bunch of
nonsense and i'd be i probably it's
probably the wrong word it's probably it
literally is bunk nonsense from a lot of
people who believe really crazy things
this one is definitely it's
just not even it's totally off the wall
and it's it's because these people you
know you saw maggie haberman she was
like trump's claiming he'll be
reinstated right it's resulted in this
really crazy parallel universe of people
who just make things up but we're going
to talk about it we're going to
obviously we're not saying it's real
it's like augmented fan fiction yeah
it's like trump fan fiction yeah it's
hilarious that'll be up but that'll be
up at timcast.com become a member you'll
see it around 11 or so and we'll see
y'all there bye
you